This is Jocko podcast number 98 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
They asked us to take off our head scarves and loosened any buttons to reveal
our chests.
That courtyard became the marketplace where Isis men came and chose girls.
They liked bill.
They first sent all the older women to another place and the women with babies
and other children to another place.
We do not know the whereabouts of these women and that includes my mother and my
sisters.
I had my period that night,
but no matter how much I told him I have my period,
he did not believe me.
He ordered me to strip naked in his room.
Then he stuck his finger in my vagina and saw that I was indeed bleeding.
Only then did he believe,
okay,
but that did not mean he left me alone.
Instead,
he put the air conditioner on a really high volume,
said that I am to sit still in my new to d the whole night and he molested me
throughout the night.
By the time morning arrived,
I was frozen both physically and psychologically.
Nothing mattered after that point.
I didn't know.
I had not seen the worst of it yet.
He would put on horrible sexual movies and we do all kinds of things.
To me.
They all had long hair and long beards,
but the worst of all is there smell.
I've never smelled such awful smell in my life.
Yeah,
they do not bathe.
They feel more like beasts than human.
Only Yazidi women are taken as slaves.
She a women,
they burn alive.
We saw one,
she,
a woman burned alive in front of us.
Christian women.
They leave on the condition that their family must pay a fee for Isis,
for being Christian in Isis territories
and Sunni women are left alone as long as they follow isis orders.
If they don't,
they are whipped and tortured.
Okay.
Some of them are the wives of our captors,
some of the wives,
whereas helpless as we were at,
some were very mean women who encouraged their men to rape us.
Okay?
As long as a girl has some breast,
she's considered a woman and that entitles them to rape her.
Some girls are as young as 10 and 11 years old.
I have no past and no future.
At the moment,
I am stuck in my anger and pain at what Isis did to my family,
my community,
and myself.
I have a new behavior that I can't stop including washing my mouth over and over
again.
There are nights I wake up more than one time to wash my mouth as I remember
what they did to me and how they forced themselves on me.
I am a dead person now.
I have no life.
I only hope that my mother comes back from capture so my life can resume.
So those are excerpts from an article that was in the New York Times by Zeynab
Salbi and the quotes are from
Layla,
which is a pseudonym who was a [inaudible] woman captured by Isis and obviously
kept as a slave.
And she eventually escaped and gave that interview in a camp in Earl Beal,
which is in northern Iraq,
which at the time was an Iraqi government controlled city.
And I would say this,
if you think that evil
does not exist in the world,
you are wrong.
It does.
And it's not just individuals scattered around.
These are groups of,
suppose it human beings that are systematically implementing heinous and evil
acts on totally innocent people.
And I have obviously talked about evil before on this podcast
20 years ago during the genocide in Rwanda
50 years ago in Vietnam during the me Lai massacre,
75 years ago,
a Nazi Germany 80 years ago when Nan king
under the Imperial Japanese army.
And those things are in the past.
But it is important to remember that evil is still happening now.
And I know that it is hard for us to see that,
especially here in America in this unbelievably well protected bubble that we
live in a bubble that is provided and protected by young and brave men and women
who volunteer to go out and hold the line.
But the evil is out there.
It always is.
And tonight
we have a guest on the podcast that I think has a very clear understanding of
evil,
of where it comes from and how it manifests itself in the world.
And he also has an incredible understanding of the good
and what we as people can do
to live our lives better for ourselves,
for our families,
for our communities,
and for the world.
His name is Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson.
And I'm not exactly sure when I her Dr. Peterson for the first time,
but as I dug into the content online,
what really struck me
was that what he was saying,
okay.
And he was an academic on unbelievably smart,
unbelievably well read person.
And yet when he said things,
they aligned almost perfectly with things that I believed in,
things that I had learned in my life.
And so here we were,
these two radically different people from different backgrounds.
One highly educated college professor,
the other a military veteran,
and a certified knuckle dragger.
And yet our thoughts were very aligned.
And the way that
I would hear him tie history and fought around human psychological evolution
into the social structure and to societal structure
and the way he laid out the maps of meaning behind the way we think it was very
useful.
And it's helped me realize that the way I feel in my gut,
my instincts about people and about the world,
they're there for a reason.
It isn't random.
There is some reason behind the way that I think and the way that we think.
So
Jordan,
thank you for coming on the show.
Very glad to be here.
That's uh,
that's quite the beginning.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
like I said,
it's very easy for people to lose track of the fact that while you're sitting in
an air conditioned space somewhere,
thinking about your next Netflix movie that you're gonna Watch,
there's PR,
there are people that are in the most horrible and heinous situations that are
being put on them by other human beings and it doesn't really stop.
Yeah.
Well it's a hard thing for people to,
to contemplate.
I mean,
there's two elements to life that are hard to contemplate.
one is that the suffering that's attendant on life fundamentally and then the
other is the malevolence of people.
And we're not in the modern world.
We don't really think about those as fundamental realities in some sense now
because we,
we tend to think about material situations as fundamental realities.
But the metaphysical realities,
the ethical realities are more real.
And it's necessary to know that in order to orient yourself properly in life.
I,
you know,
I never really took the idea of good,
seriously transcendent good,
let's say,
or ultimate good until I convinced myself of the existence of,
well,
if it wasn't the ultimate evil,
it was sufficiently ultimate for me.
You know,
cause I immersed myself in a study of the Nazi Holocaust and,
and of what happened in down king and what happened with unit seven 31 which is
the most horrifying,
that's the most horrifying material I've ever read,
which is really saying something because there's plenty of horrified material to
read and,
and what happened in the Soviet Union and what happened in Mao's China,
which,
you know,
so few people know about now.
And I,
I guess what I found most striking,
especially with regards to what happened in the Soviet Union was well and,
and,
and in Germany for that matter,
was that there were a number of people who were writing about it,
like Viktor Frankl,
psychiatrist who wrote man's search for meaning,
and also Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn who wrote the Gulag archipelago,
which should be required reading for every,
I think for every American citizen.
Um,
that,
that there was some integral relationship between the moral failings of
individuals and a catastrophic moral failings of the state.
And that that was directly causally related.
You know,
so social knits and made a great case in with regards to the analysis of the
Marxist catastrophes in the Soviet Union,
that they were tied integrity not only to,
to that dogma,
but also to the willingness of the typical citizen to swallow endless lies and,
and act them out.
And he included himself in that,
in that set of,
of,
of deceitful people,
let's say.
And it was really struck me that
because there were,
those writings are so profound.
Viktor Frankl is another good example.
You can't read that without it really punching you.
You know?
Um,
it really struck me that it really struck me that it was possible that there was
some direct integral relationship between the individual moral choices that
people made in their day to day lives and the broad scale social movements that
happened around them.
And I think I've come to believe that that's the case.
And um,
yeah,
well certainly the story that you read,
the person who was written about the rapist was making all sorts of individual
choices.
Right.
And you know,
he might've been convincing himself that he was on some kind of holy mission
man,
but I guess that would be in part so that he could stand looking at,
at himself in the mirror in the morning without running away screaming if he saw
what was really there.
So.
Well,
one of the things in in Frankel that kind of in a man's search for meaning that
definitely two points that really hit me hard when I was reading it was,
one is I,
I didn't understand the extent to which the Kappos,
which were the Jewish prisoners that got taken on board to help and would,
would get special treatment.
Number one,
I didn't realize the extent to which they were in existence.
I knew that I knew what they were,
but I didn't realize that they were,
they were as aggressive as they were.
And the other thing that hit me is,
is the the paragraph or the lines where he's saying that
the best of us didn't make it out and that if you were going to live,
you had to do things that you wouldn't want to maybe do.
And maybe if you were a a better person,
maybe you wouldn't do them.
And to me that was harsh.
I mean,
this was his admitting that that if you wanted to survive as a person in that
situation,
you might have to take someone's piece of bread,
you might have to move a number on a list to get someone else sent down to the
down to the,
uh,
execution area a day earlier than you.
And that happens to postpone your execution long enough that you can make
another move.
And that's a scary thing.
Yo,
you saw the same thing with social Knutson's description of the gulags because
they were running in large part by the inmates.
But I think that that's a really good metaphor for totalitarian states in
general.
You know,
because we like to think that a totalitarian state is made up of innocent,
oppressed individuals who are under the thumb of a,
uh,
an evil tyrant and that all of the catastrophes are cascading from the top down.
But I don't think that that's true.
I think that it's more like a holographic structure where the tyranny exists at
every single level.
So it exists psychologically and it exists within the family and it exists
within the mid level organizations.
And so,
well,
you know,
when eastern Germany for example,
one out of every three people was a government informer.
So what meant is if you had a family of six people that two of them you couldn't
trust and you can't,
you can't just say that that's a consequence of the top down structure at
tyranny is something that exists everywhere simultaneously.
Once it,
once it gets a grip and it's easy for people to say things like,
well,
I was just following orders and you know,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to put myself in a position where I'm claiming that if I was in
that position,
I wouldn't have followed orders in the same way.
I mean,
God only knows till you get there.
Right.
That's for sure.
But,
but what that did to me was focused my attention more and more on,
on,
uh,
the necessity of individual responsibility.
I thought if it was individuals in the final analysis who were responsible for
the great evils of the 20th century,
which I think is a reasonable way of conceptualizing it,
then it might be individuals who could be responsible for whatever good there
might be in mankind that could help us avoid those situations in the future.
And I thought of that as a alternative in some sense too.
Nihilistic,
disbelief and ideological possession,
you know,
cause if your group identity is too tight,
then you start acting like they like the uh,
like,
like uh,
like a cog in a mob,
not a very bad thing.
But then if your group identity disappears completely,
well then you're left alone and bereft.
And so those are bad alternatives,
right?
You're sort of damned if you do and damned if you don't.
And it,
it was,
it was very difficult to understand that there might be a third path between
those two.
I couldn't see the,
the existence of anything.
Cause people need belief systems in order to exist,
right.
To maintain psychological stability and to main maintain sociological stability
as well.
But then if the beliefs get too rigid and they turn into a raging totalitarian
mob,
so maybe you let that go because you don't want to play that game,
but then you dissolve because you have no identity.
That's not,
that's not acceptable either.
When I first laid that out,
that clearly it was really hard on me because I couldn't see a third path to
that.
But then I started to realize,
and this was a consequence all of reading,
the sorts of things that we already talked about,
but also I'm starting to understand the underlying structure of mythology and
what the heroic path meant essentially.
And that meant adoption of supreme moral responsibility as an individual.
Now there's,
there's this,
there's this idea in the new testament,
which is a really interesting idea.
You know,
it's,
it's one of these bottomless ideas and I mean that literally you could study it
forever and never get to the bottom of it.
And the idea is that Christ is the person who takes the sins of mankind on
himself and there's something redemptive about that.
And that's actually a really dark idea because what it means as far as I can
tell what it means,
at least what it means psychologically,
is that when you read these terrible things,
you have to understand that you're reading about you.
If you don't understand that you're reading about you,
then you don't actually understand the stories,
you know,
because you,
you put yourself in the position where you're automatically the good person who
would never do anything like that.
And then these other people are,
well,
they're devils in some sense,
right?
And,
and it's very easy for people to make that division,
but it's a horrific realization when you think that the devil that you see
outside is the same thing that's inside.
And that you don't know until you're put in a situation like that what you might
do.
And then it's even worse because if you look at the historical evidence,
you know,
um,
it's,
it was ordinary people in some sense that produced the catastrophes of Nazi
Germany and the Soviet Union and Maoist China.
I mean,
they might not have originated it,
but they certainly had the option to say no at different parts,
different steps along the way.
And they didn't,
you know,
and these things do happen.
One horrible thing at a time.
There's this great book called ordinary men,
um,
which,
which describes the descent of,
of a German police force from ordinary Bursch wall,
middle class men,
essentially just ordinary policemen who actually were raised before the Hitler
youth.
They weren't indoctrinated,
you know,
as young people.
Um,
and they were,
they were brought into Poland to sort of mock pop after the Germans had walked
through.
And it describes how they descended into the sort of people who would take naked
women out,
naked,
pregnant,
pregnant women out into the middle of fields and shoot them in the back of the
head.
And what's horrifying about the book is that the author,
um,
Browning,
uh,
details,
the stages by which this occurred and it's,
it's all,
for example,
the commander of this unit told the men that they were going to have to do
terrible things,
but that they could go home if they wanted to.
And then you think,
well,
there is a,
there's an out.
But,
but then if you really think about it,
you think,
well there are a tight tightly knit cause I military organization and one of the
natural thoughts under that circumstance would be,
well,
I'm not going to leave my comrades to do all the dirty work.
That would just be a matter of cowardice.
And so you can see that,
you know that there's an ethical requirement that would keep you there to begin
with.
And then they were doing what you just said,
which is taking the burden of this sinful activity on yourself.
If you let everyone else do it,
then you're not,
you're not acting heroically.
Well.
Right.
And,
and so it was easy for the men to get entrapped into that.
And then,
you know,
the requirements for their horrific action kept ramping up.
And like each time the accepted the requirement of doing one horrific thing,
the probability that they would accept the next requirement increased.
And what is also really interesting about that book,
uh,
ordinary men is that it's not like these men didn't suffer.
Like they were suffering terribly.
They were physically ill,
they were vomiting,
they were,
they were tearing themselves apart psychologically,
you know,
but they didn't quit.
So that's a,
that's a great book because if you want to know how you walk down,
the,
how you,
how you can be enticed to walk down a terrible path.
That's the book to read.
And it's very frightening because if you read it properly,
then you know,
you have to read it again,
as I said,
is if you're one of the people to whom this is happening and not the victim but
the oppressor,
you know,
and I mean,
you can also read it as the victim.
That's fair enough.
But,
but it's ordinary people who participate in these things and that's a very,
very terrifying thought.
We actually covered that book on this podcast.
Both of them.
Yeah.
Both Viktor Frankl and,
and uh,
ordinary man,
Huh?
Yeah.
Um,
it's interesting because I,
as I as I,
you know,
I've watched all your stuff read and one of the things that I was thinking about
is,
you know,
you talk about where the,
the,
the hero comes from,
where this idea comes from and how we ended up looking at these types of people
as they're good.
And it happens over ages and ages and generations and generations of saying,
well that's a good quality and that's a good quality.
And there's these 10 people that are all considered good people and they all
have this couple of qualities in common.
So those are good qualities and eventually that becomes elevated to the point
where we say that's a hero.
And when I was thinking of until that,
so that's what happens.
And now we all have this elevated thing to look at and say that's something we
could aspire to.
That's where we want to go.
That's where we wanna be.
We wanna we want to help and we want to support who we want to make sacrifices
for the tribe.
W W W how do we end up?
Or who ends up saying I see something evil and I'm going to follow in that
direction?
Well,
I think that that the story of Cain and Abel is really very tightly constructed
representation of,
of that process because I mean,
it's,
it's a very strange story because,
well,
for a variety of reasons,
first of all,
it's very ancient.
Second of all,
it's the first story about human beings mythologically speaking within the Judeo
Christian Canon,
let's say,
because Adam and eve aren't real people,
right?
Because they are formed by God.
Cain enabled are the first people and they're a pair of hostile brothers.
And so the first thing that says is that sibling tension within families is a
universal truth.
And that can get murderous.
And if you don't know that and you can't see that,
then you're not watching your children carefully enough.
So,
because what siblings can torment each other too,
to a great degree.
And it's something that you should strive diligently to observe and to quail.
Um,
but then there's this,
the next part of it that's so interesting is the idea of sacrifices is
introduced and that it took me a long time to understand what sacrifice meant,
um,
because on the surface of it,
especially the way it's acted out,
like burnt offerings and that sort of thing,
it just seems like,
well,
it seems so archaic and distant from us that it's not really comprehensible.
But partly from reading John,
I started and Nicha for that matter,
I started to understand that people often acted out conceptions before they
understood what they meant.
You know,
and we act out a lot of things we don't understand because we're much more
complex than we can represent.
So we're always acting out things we don't understand.
But so there's this idea in Cain and Abel that you have to make sacrifices in
order to stay on the good side of God.
And so I thought about that.
Um,
practically say,
not so much metaphysically but practically,
and realized that that was equivalent to the discovery of time of the future.
Because we do,
we do act and it,
and this is a peculiar discovery of human beings.
Maybe a consequence of our expanded intelligence is that we're actually aware of
the future and we actually treat the future as if it's something that you can
bargain with.
Now,
partly it's because the future is other people and they remember your
reputation,
they remember your past actions.
And if you do someone a favor,
then that favor is in some sense stored up in the future.
So you can think about the future as a place of judgment about your moral
actions.
And it's not that far from that to imagining a god who's keeping track of that
or who even is that.
But in any case,
the idea of sacrifice emerges in the story of Cain and Abel and Cain and Abel
both make sacrifices to God.
And in order to stay on his good side,
let's say.
And what a sacrifice means is that you give up something of value in the present
so that you can be so that you can improve the future.
And you know,
that's no different from what we call discipline.
It's exactly the same thing.
It's just that concretely acted out version of that.
And so,
you know,
the idea basically was that well God was in the transcendent heavens and,
and the first question would be,
well,
why is that when it's like,
if you go out and I'm really dark night and look up at the sky,
you have a sense of what's beyond you,
what,
what's transcendent,
what's infinite?
And,
and so to associate that with the highest of values is a reasonable association,
right?
From,
from a say,
from an emotional point of view.
So it's not particularly primitive.
It's a smart,
um,
metaphor or it's a smart intuition that,
that,
and it's above you.
And you know,
we tend to think of when you're moving towards an ideal that you're moving up,
that you're moving above,
you're moving to the mountain top,
right?
You're,
you're going up,
not down.
And so it all sits within that same framework.
And it's partly because when you go up,
like on a mountain,
you can see for long distances,
right?
So those,
all those things are tangled together.
So anyways,
so the idea is that you have to give up something of value now so you so that
you make the future better.
And sometimes it's even something you love now and not,
that's a good example too,
because often the things that stop us from moving forward,
our,
our attachments to things that we should no longer be attached to.
Right?
And in fact,
you can almost make that definitional if you're not moving forward in your life.
There's a high probability that you have some idea or some mode of action or
some habit that you're so in love with that you won't let go of it.
So,
all right,
so Cain and Abel Cain enabled make sacrifices.
And there's kind of a hint in the story that it's just a hint that cane
sacrifices,
they're sort of second rate.
But in any case,
it's ambivalent tape.
But,
but Abel,
he just does wonderfully well and everything works out for him.
And everyone knows people like that,
you know?
And so God accepts his sacrifices.
But for some reason he rejects canes.
And maybe it's the arbitrary ness of God or maybe it's cause Cains heart isn't
in the right place when he's making his sacrifices,
which is more likely.
And so cane goes and has a chat with God and he says basically what he says is
something like,
how in the world can you possibly justify this universe that you created?
You look at me and I'm breaking myself and half trying to adapt and to make
things right and it's not working.
And then there's this able character and things come easy to him and everything
is flourishing for him.
And so like what the hell?
And if you don't understand that question,
then you're not thinking because it's very,
very frequently the case when a serious catastrophe besets you in life that you
essentially ask exactly that question.
What's the meaning of life?
What's the purpose of the world?
How come they're suffering?
And it's easy to become resentful and vengeful as a consequence of that.
And so you got to think about what state of mind having your sacrifices rejected
puts you in,
especially when you see someone who's successful because that's where the
jealousy and resentment starts to starts to what faster is probably the right
word.
And so God says to Cain exactly what he doesn't want to hear,
which is,
well,
yeah,
okay,
but you have made lots of mistakes in your life.
So he basically says sin is at your door like a predatory and sexually aroused
animal,
and you've invited it into your house to have its way with you and produce
something creative as a consequence.
So he was used as sexual metaphor,
you know,
and so that you've willingly gone down the negative path and you've allowed that
to enter into you and,
and to operate in a creative manner and you've spun off all these terrible
thoughts and,
and this justification for not acting properly.
And that's why things aren't going well for you.
And so don't lay that at my feet,
which is the most brutal possible message he could have got.
And so then he leaves the presence of God,
let's say.
And it says in the story that his countenance fell,
which meant he was basically enraged.
And so what does he do?
He goes out and kills Abel.
And then that's,
that's a very fascinating idea because Abel is his ideal.
So it kills is ideal and when you kill your ideal,
you're lost.
And then he does that to take revenge on Abel but also to take revenge on God,
which I think is extremely interesting.
And,
and a deep,
deep idea.
Like these kids who shoot up high schools for example,
you cannot understand what they're doing unless you understand the story of Cain
and Abel.
You cannot understand what possesses them until you can understand that someone,
even someone who doesn't believe it doesn't matter.
It's the psychological state of mind that matters is they're out for revenge on
being itself.
And that's why they produce as much mayhem as possible in the shortest period of
time.
That's why they sacrifice an innocent people because it's much more vengeful
and,
and demonstrative to kill innocent people then to kill guilty people,
right?
Cause it's a worse sin,
so to speak.
And then they killed themselves.
And they killed themselves as a final demonstration of their belief in the,
in nihilism and the horror of existence.
Because you might say,
well,
why don't they just kill themselves first and save everyone the trouble?
You know?
And there's narcissism in not too,
because they know their names are going to be splashed across the page.
That's their notoriety instead of their accomplishment.
And of course,
the media is unbelievably complicit in that.
Um,
but well,
so when you're talking about motivation for evil,
then you have to understand what it is that's driving it.
And it is a deep resentment about the structure of being for being what
saturated with suffering,
but also for rejecting.
You're rejecting your sacrifices and that,
you know,
that produces the bitterness of failure.
And I'll stop with this.
One of the things that's really interesting about the old testament is that,
and the Jews in the Old Testament is that they don't take the path of cane every
time they're walloped by God,
which is like fairly frequently.
They say,
we must have done something wrong and we have to set herself right.
And that's,
uh,
an unbelievably heroic attitude because that's the alternative cursing fate.
It's like you take the responsibility for failure onto yourself and you think,
well,
if I was just,
maybe if I just had my act together a little bit more,
if I took advantage of every opportunity that was put in front of me,
if I wasn't resentful and bitter,
then I could have done something that would have tilted the situation in a
different direction.
And like that's almost inevitably true.
Well,
it's interesting and again,
this is kind of where when I would hear you say things like that.
So as you know,
I wrote a book called extreme ownership that the opening chapter of the book is
a horrible situation with a fratricide happens on the battlefield.
So friendly forces,
killing friendly forces,
some of those forces being mine.
And you know,
it's all these people I could blame and all these little incidents that happened
that I could have said,
well,
you know,
we had this radio cryptographic change that happened in the middle of operation
and it had people weren't able to talk to each other.
And we had these Iraqis that we didn't speak English and we had these units that
we hadn't worked with before and they did things we didn't expect.
And there's plenty of blame to go around.
And,
and essentially I said,
hey,
you know who's fault this is,
this is my fault.
I'm the commander.
And so when I hear you say things like that,
it strikes me that you uncovered this through your study of history and,
and philosophy and religion.
And I learned it,
you know,
as like I said,
a certified knuckle dragger out on the battlefield that realized,
you know,
if you're going to exist as a leader and as a human,
then you need to take responsibility for what happens around you.
And that's again to
take,
well now the religious notion in some senses that you have to take ultimate
responsibility.
And that in some sense,
the things that happen around you,
I mean this is
Dostoyevsky I think said something like every man is responsible for everything
that happens to him and everything that happens to everyone else.
And that's,
you know,
that,
that's,
it's a crazy statement,
right?
It's a crazy statement.
And he was a pretty extreme person in many,
many ways.
But there's a level at which that's metaphysically true,
you know,
because what happens is that it's,
it's failure to act often that's the most catastrophic,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's to not do the right thing when the,
when the situation presents itself and it's very specific.
You know,
you're constantly in situations where you could do the right thing.
If you are willing to take a risk that's actually a relatively moderate size and
you know that you could take the risk and you know that you should take the risk
and you don't.
And that happens to people all the time.
And then what happens is the thing that they didn't oppose grows a little bit
and they shrink a little bit and that starts a loop pay.
And so,
and you say,
well,
how do you take responsibility for the world?
And the answer is,
well,
you also have to do it with a certain degree of humility because what do you
know?
You know,
and this is part of the reason that I'm so opposed to the activist culture on,
on college campuses.
You don't teach 18 year olds to go and demonstrate about capitalism,
you know,
because they don't know anything.
And they have problems in their own life that needed to be solved that are
local.
And the local problems aren't trivial.
You know,
they're not disciplined.
They're there.
They're not looking at the world in a straight way.
They're not taking responsibility for themselves or for their actions,
their sexual actions among others.
They're not taking responsibility for their family.
They're not looking at how they could contribute to the community.
They don't understand the fact that they don't know anything.
And so they should be taught to start locally and to put things together that
they could put together,
you know,
to make their bed and to clean up the room and to attend their classes with
regularity if they're going to university because that's part of the implicit
contract and to straighten up the things around them that are actually within
their to straighten up.
And then what happens is that if you do that,
let's say religiously,
which I suppose would be the same as in a discipline manner,
that your realm of influence starts to grow,
but it grows in a positive way.
Just like you can go,
you can take,
you can end up in hell one step at a time and that's extraordinarily well
documented.
You can end up at the opposite place of that one step at a time.
But it's also that same gradual process.
You don't get to leap from being a 17 year old,
not head who doesn't know anything and who isn't disciplined to the critic of
Judeo Christian society.
You just don't know enough to do that.
Especially when you can look at your own life and think about how many things
that you're doing that you know are wrong,
that you could fix,
that you aren't fixing.
And that's the crucial thing.
It's,
it's this isn't this,
this mode of thinking isn't asking people to stretch themselves beyond what
they're capable of.
It's just asking them to stretch themselves to the point that they are capable
of and seeing what happens.
And that works.
It works.
I've had many people write me over the last year and this is a great thing,
really.
It's a great thing.
Who said that they stopped,
started to tell the truth,
or at least not to lie,
because who can tell the truth?
Right?
But at least you can not lie.
And that they started to put things in order around them that they could put an
order in that,
you know,
the positive things just started to happen,
like mad and they're not nihilistic and they've got a purpose in their life.
And so,
you know,
thank God for that.
And it does work.
So I was trying to think of how to stop the loop of my sacrifices have been
rejected.
And,
and the way that you stop that loop is instead of saying the sack,
my sacrifices were rejected.
So my hard work,
my effort,
my everything that I'm doing to try and move forward,
it's not working.
And,
and if you want to go towards hell,
you keep saying,
well,
it's,
it's not working,
but it's,
but it's because of everyone else.
It's,
they're rejecting me.
They're not accepting what I've done.
Whereas if you say to yourself,
oh,
it didn't work,
okay,
it's my fault.
What can I do better?
And that's how you start moving in the other direction,
which is,
yeah,
well,
at least you have control.
And you know,
you don't even necessarily have to think it's your fault,
although that's,
that's a reasonable way of looking at it.
You could,
you could minimally just accept the fact that it's your responsibility.
You're stuck with it,
and you could actually change it.
And once you know too,
that if you're failing repeatedly,
um,
then there's probably something wrong.
It's possible that there's something wrong with the way that you're
conceptualizing the world.
Cause you have a choice,
right?
If,
if you keep making sacrifices and they don't work,
there's a binary choice and one is,
well there's something wrong with the structure of reality.
And the other is there's something wrong with your approach.
And so then you might say,
well let's take the first idea.
There's something wrong with the structure of reality.
It's like you're really going to say that are you?
He really gonna come out and say,
I know enough to judge the nature of being.
And then the alternative is also quite frightening because then you know you,
it's you that's making the mistakes.
And you might be wrong at a really deep level.
And that might mean that a lot of you has to burn off and be transformed.
Maybe even things about yourself that you think are admirable than that you like
because your position,
you know,
you're yourself.
Conceptualization is so warped and wrong and that's really daunting.
But you know when people set themselves up as the judge of being,
I mean I've written about this a fair bit in my new book,
which is called 12 rules for life.
When people set themselves up as the judge of being,
then they take on what can only be described as a kind of satanic arrogance
because they've actually taken to themselves the moral right to criticize the
structure of existence itself.
It's like you better be careful when you do something like that because you're
setting yourself up as the judge of being in the Columbine kids did that.
Like if you read what they wrote,
it's,
that's exactly what happened and that's exactly what they say is that I've taken
onto myself the task of the judge of being unfounded wanting and so I'm going to
cause as much mayhem as I possibly can before I,
you know,
before I depart.
And that's a very common story among people who do that sort of thing.
It's,
and it's so interesting because every time something like that happens,
people go,
well,
we don't understand.
It's like,
no,
you won't understand because they write about what they're doing.
They tell you why they're doing it,
but it's so it cuts too close to the bone for people.
And so they think,
well,
we don't understand how that can happen.
You know,
like there was a while back,
I think it was in Connecticut where there a bunch of elementary school kids
shot,
right?
Because this is kind of a one upmanship game and it's bad enough to shoot high
school kids,
but it's even worse to shoot kindergarten and elementary kids because they are
even clearly more innocent.
It's like,
well that's,
that's part of that vengeful spirit,
you know,
better to punish the innocent and the guilty.
If you're trying to make a statement about your,
your hatred for the structure of reality and these things,
you have to understand these things really,
you have to understand the matter religious level of analysis because there's
no,
well,
that's what happens when you encounter evil is that you're in to the domain that
can only be described by religious ideation.
And I,
I don't say that lightly.
You know,
I'd had many veterans come to talk to me now and there are people who had post
traumatic stress disorder and they've said that listening to my lectures has
helped them out a lot because it's provided them with a Philips philosophy of
good and evil.
And if you have post traumatic stress disorder,
you need a sophisticated philosophy of good and evil because otherwise you don't
have any place to put your experiences and that fragments and shatters you.
It's,
it's no,
it's no trivial matter to be touched by malevolence or to have it manifest
itself within you unexpectedly.
You know,
it,
it's physiologically destructive.
It,
it shatters people and you have to move from a naive interpretation of the world
to a very deep interpretation of the world if you're ever going to dig yourself
out of that hole.
No,
that's,
that's interesting.
In one of the,
one of the things that I was going to tell you or ask you about,
so when I was a kid,
I wanted to be a commando.
Like I don't really remember wanting to do anything else.
When I realized that there was that role that you could play in life.
That's what I wanted to do.
And,
and a lot of my friends in the seal teams were the same way.
That's what they wanted to do.
And as soon as they figured out like,
oh that's,
that exists,
oh,
I can do that and I just have to sign this piece of paper and go do this stuff
and then that's what I'll be.
Where does that come from?
Well,
I mean that,
that's a very good question.
I mean,
I would say it's temperamental.
You know,
people differ tremendously in their temperaments.
And to think that there's a warrior temperament is a perfectly reasonable thing
to think.
I mean,
there's been whole cultures,
many,
many cultures who are devoted to fostering that warrior mentality.
You know,
where if you weren't like that you were the outlier.
I would say that's probably true of most human cultures across most of time.
You know,
we've been fortunate enough to live in relatively peaceful times,
at least the vast majority of us.
So the necessity for that,
like right at the edges of actual warfare is much less than it might be under
other historical circumstances.
But,
but it's,
it's,
it's a deep part of,
of,
of many people's nature.
And so the question is what do you do with that?
Right.
And I mean,
one alternative potential potentially is criminal behavior.
And you know,
the fact that so many people like watching movies about bad guys,
you know,
is an indication of how attractive that is to people.
And I think the reason for that is,
is that while Nietzsche observed at one point that most of what people regard as
morality is just cowardice.
And what he meant by that was that people don't do bad things,
not because they're good,
but because they're afraid to do the bad things.
And then when they see people do the bad things that are actually really deeply
attracted by that,
because it speaks to part of them that could go beyond the rules.
And that's actually a necessary part.
It's a really necessary part.
Like you don't make men safe by making them weak.
In fact,
they're much more dangerous when they're weak because they'll stab you in the
back when they get the chance or take advantage of you when you,
when they get the chance you make men safe,
let's say by making them strong and then by making sure that they're
disciplined.
And so,
you know,
you've got people like you've got this let's say warrior mentality.
That's a deep part of their temperament.
And then you have some choices about what you might do with that.
You might try to discipline it and bring it under control and integrated into
your character in which it then it can make you someone who stalwart and
indomitable and,
and who will move forward,
you know,
in the face of tremendous risk.
And while that's the optimal,
that's the optimal pathway,
if you have that kind of temperament.
I,
and I,
I think like it's the men that have the most,
what would you call it?
It's not aggressive exactly.
But we'll,
we'll,
we'll leave it at that aggressive and fearless temperaments.
That can be the best man,
but it's like having a very powerful dog.
You better civil,
you better discipline it because otherwise it's going to be a monster.
Yeah,
well I had the F I was a rebellious kid,
right.
And I could have easily gone down the path of crime.
And as a matter of fact,
many of my friends that I,
you know,
left when they stayed in the house at home,
they did end up as criminals and having big trouble with the law or going down
even paths of drugs and everything else that you can get into.
But,
but when we were kids or younger,
everyone kind of had the same thing.
But like you said,
I kind of,
I so lucky because I just signed that piece of paper and I,
and I saw that I could do something and I could take all that aggression in all
that energy.
I could do something that was good and positive.
And,
and we joke about that in the seal teams that many guys,
you,
you actually to be a good seal,
you sort of,
you sort of have this criminal mindset that you've,
you've somehow harnessed and you keep under control most of the time.
Yup.
And occasionally it does get out of hand and we got guys that get in trouble and
that happens.
And if we,
if we only took guys that would never get in trouble,
we wouldn't have any one in the ranks really well.
Well you
also see too in the classic hero stories,
I mean you see this with Harry Potter for example,
which I'm making reference to because it was such a phenomenon.
I mean,
when,
when when something makes a welfare mother richer than the queen of England,
you shouldn't take note,
right?
When,
when kids are reading 500 page books and,
and,
and standing in line waiting for the next one.
And when you produce a whole movie empire around something,
you should take note of that.
Well,
Harry Potter's little team aren't the delinquents,
right,
who have no discipline,
but they're also not the good kids.
They're the kids who will break rules when necessary.
And that's,
that's the issue.
Break rules when necessary.
Now the question is,
when is that necessary?
Well,
that's sort of the ultimate ultimate ethical choice.
But you know,
your,
why did that work for you?
Do you think?
You know,
like what,
why was it,
well,
two questions.
One would be why did you decide to step into a discipline structure be,
I mean that's obviously difficult and why do you think you did that?
And some of the other kids that you knew that were like,
you didn't,
it was really one of the most rebellious things that I could do was to join the
military.
So I come from a small new England town.
People get done with high school,
they go to college,
they get a job as whatever.
People get jobs as they follow that very normal path.
And I didn't even know anyone that joined the military.
And,
and so that was the most rebellious thing I could do.
Oh,
college,
no education.
No,
I'm going to go be a commando.
That's what I'm going to do.
And,
and it was the most rebellious thing I could do.
I think that's one of the reasons why I did it.
It was also a complete break away from family.
Okay.
I have,
I love no reliance on you.
You know,
I'm going,
you don't have to worry about me anymore.
I'm done.
Um,
I will not rely on anyone else.
I will be self-reliant,
which I wanted to do.
And so I think those are the main things that that got me there.
And then what's great about it for me was when I got there,
you have a completely blank slate and you have very clear directions of what you
need to do to,
to ascend the,
the dominance hierarchy.
You do this,
you do this,
you follow these rules.
You,
you literally fold your underwear in this way when you're going through bootcamp
and you get a better grade on your military performance.
So they give you very clear rules that you're supposed to follow and very clear
tasks that you had to do.
And,
and it was great for me because it was a blank slate because when I was in high
school,
I was,
uh,
I was a screw up.
Not Bad,
but not good.
And,
and so I hadn't really set myself up properly and now all of a sudden,
all I had to do that,
that was all gone.
It didn't matter that the past did not matter at all.
I had a completely blank slate.
If you do this stuff properly,
you'll,
you'll do well at,
you'll ascend that.
That's a very interesting thing because then it's not merely a matter of
following a set of arbitrary rules.
It's following a set of rules that have a clear path to success.
Right?
That's a very different thing.
And,
and that,
that's also something that's honest because the rules of the game are well
established and then if you play it properly,
you get to win.
And that's a big deal as well.
You know,
and you mentioned,
um,
the seal types and I've met a number of people like that.
Um,
you know,
they're,
they're capable of breaking rules,
let's say,
or maybe even inclined to break them.
But I also think that,
that this is part of the reason that I'm an admirer of Carl Young because young
makes it very clear that,
see,
he was very interested in the barriers to enlightenment because if there's,
if there's such a thing as being enlightened,
let's say,
then why isn't everyone enlightened?
If it's just a matter of,
of taking the glorious,
um,
uh,
route.
And,
and following your bliss,
let's say.
It's like,
well,
that sounds pretty easy.
Why isn't everyone enlightened?
But Young's thinking isn't like that at all.
You know,
he,
he believed that in order transform your personality,
that first of all,
you had to be disciplined,
that's for sure.
But you also had to integrate that part of you that was terrible and capable of
breaking rules and make it part of you.
And so then,
and I really liked that idea.
Well here,
here's an example.
So about 20 years ago,
I would say there was a newspaper headline in one of Canada's major newspapers,
and it was the minister of foreign affairs at that time,
Lloyd Axworthy.
And he was talking about what had happened with,
uh,
Milosevic in,
in the former Soviet Union and Yugoslavia and the atrocities that were being
committed.
And he said that he,
that he was caught unawares by that because he didn't have the imagination for
that kind of evil.
And I thought,
well,
you know,
you think that what you're doing is signaling your virtue by making a statement
like that.
But from my perspective,
all you're doing is stating your cowardice and your historical ignorance.
Because if you're going to be minister of foreign affairs,
you bloody well better have imagination for that kind of evil.
Because if you don't,
then anyone who does wins,
they beat you.
And so you,
you know,
and again,
in the Harry Potter stories you see he's touched by evil,
right?
He actually has a soul fragment that's embedded within them.
That's as black as anything can possibly be.
That's why he could talk to snakes.
But without that he wouldn't be able to have any victory.
And that's exactly right.
Psychologically,
unless you can think the way that an evil person thinks,
then you're defenseless against them because they'll go places you can't imagine
it and then they win.
And so the best man I've met,
it was interesting even when I was in junior high and high school because most
of my friends dropped out.
You know,
by the time they are grade 10 thereabouts.
And a lot of them were guys who develop physically.
They're pretty powerful and they're just damn sick and putting up their hand to
go to the bathroom.
I was like,
you know,
there are not doing that anymore.
One of my friends got kicked out when he sort of challenged the gym teacher,
you know,
physically and the gym teacher,
he could do an iron cross.
He was a tough guy and so it was no trivial matter for my friend to stand up to
him.
But he got expelled anyways.
But you know,
I noticed that it wasn't,
it was often the kids whose character I admired that either quit or got expelled
and they were the tougher guys who were just sick and tired of following rules
that didn't take into account their character.
And then they'd go off and work in the oil rigs or whatever.
You could do that.
And Alberta at that time,
that was really hard work,
you know?
So it wasn't like they were necessarily taking the easy path,
but like a harmless man is not a good man.
A good man is a very,
very dangerous man who has that under voluntary control.
And you know,
you also see that,
um,
like one of the central female stories,
let's say,
um,
if the hero archetype is the central mail story,
there are variants of hero archetypes that are relevant to women.
And one of them is beauty and the beast.
And you know,
beauty isn't interested in the guy who isn't the beast.
She's interested in the
guy who's the beast.
And that's exactly right.
But she's interested in the guy who's the beast that can be civilized and
disciplined,
right?
And who can use that in the service while let's say of a family.
And that's exactly,
well that's exactly how it should be.
So I gave a speech,
uh,
one of my very good friends got married,
a few years ago and I gave a speech and at this speech he was a friend of mine
seal.
And at the speech I was talking about what it was to be a man and what,
when I felt like I was a man.
And I said there was three things that I,
that I felt,
let me transition from being,
you know,
mentally insecure about who I was as a person to being,
okay,
I'm actually good with who I am.
Number one was learning how to fight and you know,
I got into Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and mixed martial arts and I,
and I learned how to fight and now all of a sudden when I looked at other
people,
I didn't,
I wasn't posturing.
I wasn't trying to pretend that I was tough.
I was,
I knew that most people that I would encounter,
I could defeat in a physical altercation.
That was number one.
Number two was going into combat because even though you might be tougher than
him,
you know,
street fight or a no,
a fistfight with someone when you're facing death.
Well that's a whole nother level.
And for me going into combat,
well,
what was I going to act like?
Was I going to be scared?
Was I going to be a coward?
Was I going to be scared of death?
And when I went into combat,
I wasn't,
I was fine.
I was okay with the fact that I could die and,
and I was okay with that and I made good decisions and,
and did what I was supposed to do.
And the last one was I got married and had kids because all of a sudden all of
these things,
these being aggressive and working to fight and be able to destroy in an
efficient way.
Well then I took that and combined it with,
okay,
now I'm going to take care of these,
my wife and our children and that's what I'm going to do.
And my point in giving this speech was he was a guy that had learned how to
fight.
He was a guy that had been in combat and now there was one more step to take,
which was,
okay,
now you're going to get married and you're going to take care of these people.
So it's interesting that once again,
that dichotomy that,
that you talk about,
it fits perfectly into the way I figured things out.
As a,
as a guy that went to high school and joined the military.
It's kind of,
it's kind of crazy,
but it reinforces what you always say,
which is that there's,
there's deeper meaning.
There's a reason why I'm thinking that.
And the reason is because I've,
because of the things that you talk about in the way these things are overlaid
throughout history for human beings to have gotten to this point.
Yeah.
Well you acted it out,
you know,
which is what you're supposed to do.
And it's also,
it's better to act it out and to understand it,
you know,
that's,
that's best.
It's better.
It's better to understand it and not out then to not
understand it at all.
But the best is to act it out and understand it and cause then you can,
you know,
then then the way that you represent the world and yourself is in accordance
with the way that you act.
And that's,
that's,
that's optimized.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's something that I was kind of acting out again.
No,
no real guy.
Like my guidelines where like I was raised in the seal teams.
Yeah.
That was sorta my guidelines.
And,
and here's a good example.
When I first gotten the seal teams,
there's no war going on.
So what did,
what did a good seal?
Do you know what you did?
You went out and drank and got in bar fights.
That's what a good seal did.
So,
you know what I did,
went out and drank,
gotten bar fights.
That's what,
okay,
that's what I'm supposed to do.
It took me awhile to figure out,
oh,
there's actually something more than that.
Like we're actually supposed to be preparing for war and,
and,
and so now,
like you said,
I definitely acted things out and sort of was on a decent path.
But as I got older and more mature and to this day,
as I can look around and,
and actually overlay the understanding on the way of carried out,
my life is very,
it's very helpful to me.
And it's also helps me explain it to other people that see the path at Alma go.
They,
they liked that path.
They would like to join me on that path.
And I get guys that when I was in,
I,
you know,
I Kinda,
I look like a serial killer for all practical purposes.
That's the way I come across right now.
There was creepy enough,
there's,
there's guys that would,
um,
you know,
guys that would work for me are guys that would be around me and they'd see me
and they'd kind of latch on to the fact that I was tough and aggressive and,
and,
and some of those guys,
they wouldn't catch the other part,
which was that I was politically savvy and I was working and I was maneuvering
it.
I was,
you know,
figuring things out and talking to my boss in such a way that we could get where
we needed to be.
And I was doing that whole other side.
And so I'd get these guys that would end up not doing as well as they should do
because they were just,
hey,
Jocko is just ultra aggressive and he gets after it.
And so that's what I'm going to do.
And I'll be in the same place.
The guys that would do well with the guys that said,
Oh yeah,
Jack was awesome and he's aggressive and he gets after it.
He's also working and he's also maneuvering.
And he's also massaging the egos of the people around him.
So it makes sure that they get positioned in the right spot where they can go to
war policy in the right way.
And,
and so as I've gotten older,
I've been able to tell people that more clearly.
Like,
Hey,
it's not just about that side of the ultra aggressive.
You gotta be aggressive.
You've got to be willing to fight,
you got to be a willing to kill,
and you've gotta be willing to die at the same time,
you gotta be able to tamper and temper all those things in such a way that they
can be controlled and disciplined.
Well,
I also think that that's part of what makes a world peaceful in the,
in the final analysis,
because if you're around people who are dangerous but disciplined,
then everyone watches their step.
And that's exactly what should happen.
Everybody should watch their step.
And if you do,
if there's no reason for that,
then while there's no,
there's no sanction for,
for poor behavior for example,
like I mean if you,
if you're going to discipline a child,
the child has to be convinced that you're
a force that's worthy of paying attention to,
you know,
I see kids,
I,
there's a chapter in my book called don't ever,
don't let your children do anything that makes you dislike them.
And I'm pretty happy about this chapter,
although I suspect it will be rather controversial.
And it's predicated first on observation that many people hurt their children
physically and psychologically,
you know,
cause everyone gets sentimental about the relationship between parents and
children.
But that's especially in relationship to themselves because they think,
well,
you know,
of course I'm going to be a good parent.
It's like it's not so bloody obvious that you're going to be a good parent,
you know?
And so,
and then what I see happening with people who don't know how to discipline their
children is that the children run roughshod over them in there,
let's call them a hierarchical disputes because children push for position and
hierarchy and they do that behaviorally to sort of feel out the contours of the
social structure.
So you know your kid whacked perfectly fine at home,
let's say at the dinner table,
but then you take them to a stranger's dinner table and all of a sudden they act
out and you think,
what's up with you,
your little monster.
And what's up is that they're trying to figure out what the power structure is
in the new,
they don't know this of course,
but they're acting this out there trying to figure out if the same rules apply
in this new situation as apply in the old situation.
And they can't ask that and they don't even know that they are rules.
Exactly there regularities that they've learned.
And so they'll test and test and then you have to show them that.
Yeah,
it's the same here.
It's the same in this situation,
but lots of parents are very uneasy with disciplining their children.
Partly because there they believe that if you give a child infinite freedom
that's best for them and that constraints are inappropriate,
which is really just,
well I don't know what to say about that except it's so untrue that that it's
very difficult to think of anything that's more untreated now.
But also the thing is,
is if you let your children take advantage of you,
if you have an ounce of spine and an ounce of aggression,
which you do,
especially if you don't admit it,
then you will take revenge on your children.
You know?
So if they have a temper tantrum in the grocery store and embarrass you,
which child who's county can do quite effectively,
you know,
because you wouldn't let them have that pack of crayons or a chocolate bar and,
and then you know,
you,
you tell yourself it's okay and that you still,
you know,
that that really didn't make you that angry and it's okay,
but you're fuming inside and then you go home and half an hour later maybe the
child is doing some interesting little bit of work,
maybe artwork or something or does something good and comes up for a reward.
It's like the probability that you're going to reward that child properly under
those circumstances,
zero,
you're going to take the opportunity to take your revenge.
And if you don't know that,
then you're not much of a parent.
And so part of the trick with kids is that if your child is doing something that
makes you dislike them,
that you have to figure out how to stop them from doing that and teach them how
to do it properly.
And you have to talk to your wife to make sure that you're not being too much of
a monster,
you know,
on the same with her.
But that,
that discipline is partly what enables you to continue to like your child.
Well you love them.
And even more than that,
you know,
parents talk about fostering self esteem and fostering creativity in all of that
in their kids.
And I think that's misbegotten uh,
it's shallow for a variety of reasons.
First,
it's not that easy to foster creativity because it's rare and self esteem is a
very badly defined concept and mostly it's been used for harm.
Not Good.
What your job is as a parent is to help your child learn from between two years
old and say four years old how to act in the world so that when people encounter
them,
people smile and are happy they're around.
Because then,
you know,
I've seen kids who behave badly and everywhere they go,
people were false smiles and everywhere they go,
people are relieved when they leave.
And that means you think about that world from the child's perspective.
Everyone's lying and all,
everyone hates them.
That's their world.
And then if you have your child,
you know,
capable of adhering to minimal social requirements,
like maybe being able to sit at the table in a civilized manner for an hour and
being grateful for being fed,
let's say,
and knowing how to share and knowing how to pay attention to adults and,
and not having that,
you know,
that kind of
terrible cynicism and,
and arrogance that can develop even in a four year old child who's always had
its way then then they'll interact with adults in a manner that bring out the
best and the adults.
And every year they go,
everyone smiles at them and pats them on the head,
maybe even tells them useful and interesting things.
And so the whole world opens up for them.
And that's all a consequence of you having enough courage to admit to yourself
that your child can do things that you don't like and that you will take it out
on them if you don't straighten it out.
And people don't like that idea because they think,
well,
I'd never do anything.
You know,
I love my child,
I'd never do anything to hurt them.
It's like,
yeah,
God,
right?
You know,
you're so,
you're so asleep.
If you think that,
that,
that there's almost no hope for you.
You have to think I'm way bigger than this child and I'm way meaner and I'm way
trickier and I'm way more unpredictable.
And so I better be very careful in my relationships with this child so that the
worst of me doesn't come out.
And then that gives you enough intelligence to make a disciplinary framework
that's minimal and enforce it properly and carefully and then you can have an
unbelievably good relationship with your kids.
So,
and this idea of discipline,
obviously I talk about discipline a lot and one of the,
you were talking about earlier
with regards to veterans and people that have listened to your lectures.
And it's the same thing with me.
People that listen to this podcast or,
or read the books.
And,
and one of the things that I've noticed and I've talked about and I've gotten a
lot of positive feedback on is,
you know,
when you're in the military,
you have this discipline and beyond that,
beyond the discipline that's imposed on you,
you also have a lot that you have to just hold the line yourself.
I mean,
when you're in the military,
sure you go through boot camp where there's a drill instructor that yelling and
all that.
But once you're in the military,
you're doing what you have to do.
It's self discipline that you learn that and you become self disciplined.
And what happens is guys get out and that's,
that's gone.
And that hurts them.
And the other thing that hurts them is they don't know what their mission is
anymore.
And,
and my big thing with people that I've been telling vets now is find what your
next mission is.
Go find whatever your next mission.
And I don't care what it is,
but it has to be something.
And I was listening to you talk on something the other day and,
and you were,
you were talking about how
not doing anything when people are not going anywhere,
when they're,
when they're failing,
when they don't have the drive,
it's because they're not accepting responsibility for anything.
And,
and so my way of saying that is like you need a new mission,
you need to be responsible for something and you need to go and move towards
some new mission and,
and do you encounter people that,
or you see people that's very problematic in the civilian side as well,
where people,
they just don't know what they're doing.
They don't take any responsibility for it.
Yeah.
That's part of this nihilism is that because first of all,
you learned that truth is relevant relative and that there's no real moral order
and you know,
that alleviates,
you have responsibility.
And that's why that's such an attractive message to people.
But the problem is,
is that it kills you.
It kills your soul,
so to speak.
Because,
well,
when we can talk about this technically.
So you know,
there are systems,
neurological systems that underlie your experience of negative emotion.
And there are neurological systems that underlie your experience of positive
emotion.
And there are separate systems.
They obviously interact,
but they're separate systems.
So,
but the positive emotion system,
while there's two of them,
but one of them sort of kicks in when you get something that you want.
So you know you're hungry and you eat and that feels good.
And so that's kind of the simple one.
Um,
but there's a more sophisticated one that I think is even more active in people.
and it's the one that tells you that you're moving forward towards something
worthwhile.
And that's actually the one that gives people that sense of meaningful
engagement in their life on a moment to moment basis.
So,
and,
and it's also,
it's also something that doesn't have to go away.
Like if you're hungry and you eat well,
that's good,
but it's over and you're onto the next thing,
right?
It's not exactly sustaining,
it's just necessary.
That's called consumer Tory reward.
By the way.
There's other reward system has incentive reward and the incentive reward system
works on dopamine.
This neurochemical dopamine,
which is also the neurochemical tracks that opiates and cocaine and
amphetamines,
the drugs that people really like to abuse alcohol often for some people,
um,
activate.
And so you might say if you don't have enough meaning in your life,
then you're more prone to addiction.
And that's definitely the case.
Even with rats.
If you take a rat and you put them in a cage by himself and he has nothing to
do,
and then you give him access to cocaine,
he'll get addicted to the point where he won't do anything but take cocaine.
But if you throw the rat back in with a bunch of other rats and he gets to do
rat things,
then it's very hard to get them addicted to cocaine.
And so the purposeless rat is prone to addiction.
Well,
it's the same with human beings.
Now here's a corollary to that,
which is really cool.
So the magnitude of the reward you experience as you're moving towards a goal is
proportionate to the importance of the goal.
So that means the more important the goal you pick,
the more possibility there is for the kind of reward.
Let's say it's,
it's really a state of being that is life affirming and it is directly life
affirming in that,
you know,
like if you're in a football game and you're,
and it's an important football game and maybe you break a finger and you know,
normally that's,
that's a problem.
It hurts and you're going to stop doing whatever you're doing.
But if you're right in the middle of the game,
then you'll be so amped up on this reward system that it's analgesic,
it stops the pain,
it also suppresses anxiety.
So if you have a purpose,
then it's analgesic.
It takes some of the pain out of life.
It's very positive in that it motivates and energizes you and focuses you and
makes you able to remember and pay attention and it quells fear.
And so those things are all direct.
And so then you might think,
well,
what's the best possible goal while in that's,
that's the purpose I would say,
of religious training and philosophical training.
It's like,
just what the hell are you doing in the world?
You know,
when I would say,
well that's actually fairly easy to also,
um,
to also lay out,
and this is why nihilism is a much weaker philosophical position than it might
appear to be.
It's like,
well,
there are lots of terrible things happening in the world.
If you're not,
I don't care if you're a believer and atheist or,
or cynic of the highest sword.
You listened to his story,
like the one that you wrote read at the beginning of the,
of this podcast and no one says,
well,
in 100,000 years,
who the hell cares?
So why does it matter?
No one says that they listened to that,
not if they're human,
they listened to that store and they think that's not good.
It's like,
that's right.
That's not good.
It's not good.
You should do something about that because it's,
it's,
it's self,
evidently not good.
So you might say,
well at least you can start your self organization
by improving those things around you that are self evidently not good.
And that's easy,
man.
Anybody can do this.
You can sit down for 10 minutes,
say,
well,
I'm going to be honest with myself.
Like,
oh,
that's a horrible thing to do.
I'm going to be honest with myself.
Okay,
I'm probably doing a dozen stupid things that I could quit doing that are making
my life less,
more wretched and also the people around me.
And so you think,
okay,
what are those things?
And you know,
if you really want to know,
you have to want to know and you're going to get a bunch of information that you
don't want to hear,
but you'll know it's true and you already knew it in some sense.
And then you can ask yourself,
okay,
that's sucks and it's miserable and it's not very self affirming.
Um,
is there one of those things?
I would,
I would be willing to do something about that.
I would actually do something about that.
I could do something about that.
I would do something about,
which is also another horrible question because soon as you get an answer to
that,
then you have a responsibility,
right?
It's like,
Oh God,
I have to go do that.
And it's something you don't want to do.
You don't want to do it.
That's why you've been avoiding it.
And so then it's right in front of you and it's like,
it's some little trivial,
horrible thing that you're not going to get a pat on the back for.
No one's going to give you an award for it.
And,
and most people would just say,
Jesus,
you should have done that a long time ago.
You're more on and,
but then you go do it.
That's kind of humility I would say.
And then you keep doing that and it's like there's this injunction in the new
testament against praying in public,
you know,
and it's like virtue signaling.
So like you don't pray in public because then you go out and you show everybody
just what a great believer you are and how good you are.
It's like,
well,
that's what you're doing.
You're not trying to get your act together.
That's something you do in private at home.
You think,
okay,
what kind of Moron am I and what stupid things it might do it.
And then what could I possibly do to get rid of one of those a little bit now?
Well,
anybody can do that.
And that's associated with these great evils,
you know,
in,
in this way that we've already described.
It's like you're constraining your improving your character and you're
constraining the kinds of actions and perceptions that you have that are going
to make you sick of life and work against it.
Because failure does that.
That's the cane story.
It's like,
keep screwing up,
man.
See what happens if you think that isn't going to make you bitter.
And if that isn't going to make you vengeful,
and if that isn't gonna make you work to hurt people around you,
or at least not to help them,
which is the same thing,
then you're just not paying attention.
Everyone knows that's true.
So while that's responsibility,
right?
And then,
so you take on this great task of putting yourself together,
it gives your life meaning.
And that also helps you be brought trust against the fact that there's lots of
suffering in life.
And there's lots of malevolence.
It's like,
yeah,
true man.
Absolutely.
It's worse than you think even.
But
you can do more about it than you think.
And there's nothing in it except good.
But you also have to take responsibility.
So that's the thing.
You got to decide if that's what you're going to do,
but you don't get to whine about it if you don't because you haven't tested it.
People don't even have to look for some grand,
uh,
goal in the sky.
Some elevated goal of what they're going to do,
whether it's a financial goal,
whether it's uh,
uh,
a nonprofit goal and they're gonna they could look around their bedroom and
figure out what they're going to do right now to improve things.
Things
I learned from reading soldier knits is he talked about his moral transformation
in the camps and he said the first thing that transformed him to some degree was
looking at people in the camps who did refuse to do immoral things no matter
what he said.
He ran into people like that.
And that just blew him away because you already laid that out.
It's like these are,
he said they were continually choosing between their life and their conscience
and they chose their conscience like,
and,
and he tells some amazing stories in the Gulag archipelago about,
you know,
dozens of people.
He meant like that,
Matt like that.
And they're just,
they're stories that of heroism,
moral heroism under absolutely vicious conditions there.
You just can't believe them,
you know,
so,
so that's pretty amazing.
But he said that once he kind of figured out that there was a difference between
attending to your conscience and doing whatever was necessary to prolong your
miserable existence,
that he started to think about that deeply and that he went over his life with a
fine tooth comb and tried to figure out everything he did that he knew was
wrong.
And then to try to figure out what he could do in the present to rectify that.
You know,
you wouldn't necessarily be able to,
to a tone that's the right,
that's the right way of thinking about it.
You know,
you,
you do something wrong and well maybe you can't even fix it with the person you
did the wrong tube.
But maybe there's something else you could do that would be good enough so that
you know,
you can think,
okay,
well at least those balance out and maybe I'm a little bit on the side of the
positive.
So we did that,
you know,
and that he said that straightened them out a lot.
And then he wrote this book,
this amazing book that,
you know,
cut the communist intellectuals off at their knees and,
and change the world.
Really.
And that's a hell of a thing for someone to do who's,
uh,
you know,
miserable Zach and in a concentration camp,
that's a hell of a story man.
And it's not the only one like it.
So you don't know how much power you have,
where you stand,
even if you look weak and,
and,
and if what's around you is terrible.
Well then you've got lots of things to do,
that's for sure.
And they're announcing themselves right there so and
well,
and it's tying it in with evil and suffering that is best for me because it's so
real.
You know,
it's like you can be skeptical about the existence of the good,
but if you,
if you open eyes and you do any amount of studying and even any amount of self
examination,
you can't be skeptical about the existence of evil.
I don't believe that you can,
there are things that read about unit seven 31 and then see how skeptical you
are about evil.
I wouldn't recommend that by the way,
because that's,
that is so horrible that you can't really read it without being traumatized.
It is unbelievably horrible.
You read that and then you say,
well morality is relative.
It's like see if you can utter those words after reading that and then if
mortality isn't relative and there is evil,
then there is good.
It's at least whatever isn't evil.
Right.
You can whatever doesn't cause that is good.
It's sort of defining it by its opposite,
but that's okay.
It doesn't matter.
It's good enough.
And so how do,
how do guys,
going back to the PTSD conversation a little bit,
how do you guys that sort of experienced this evil part of not only of the world
but of themselves because they had to do some things that they didn't want to do
or they didn't like doing and things that made them feel like,
oh,
there's a dark part of me that I don't really like too much.
What's the,
what's the,
you know,
from what I've said is you got to embrace that,
that the fact that there's darkness in the world and that there's darkness in
you,
you got to embrace that and get a hold of it.
Not try and disguise it,
not try and make it seem like it's not there.
That's the same thing you're saying,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
when you're in really,
they say there's no atheists in foxholes,
you know,
and,
and that's,
that's,
you know,
it's a bit of a cliche but,
but there's,
there's a deep truth in that,
which isn't,
there's some circumstances that you find yourself in four,
which only religious language works.
And if you happen to do,
observe yourself doing something that's highness enough to damage you
psychologically,
then you're in the realm of good and evil.
Archetipal good and evil.
And,
and unless you can start to conceptualize the world in that manner,
you're never going to make sense out of it.
And so partly it depersonalizes it,
you know,
it's,
it's you that did this,
but it's like the capacity for evil isn't just you.
It's,
it's part of humanity.
Maybe it's part of the structure of the cosmos.
And you happened to stumble over it naively.
And so it hurt you.
You know,
there's this old Egyptian story about a god named Horace and he's the god of
attention.
So he's represented by the Egyptian I,
so he pays attention.
He's also a falcon.
And Falcon has great vision and flies above everything,
right?
And,
and,
uh,
he's also the,
the forest that revitalizes the dead father in,
in Egyptian mythology,
but he has a fight with his evil uncle set,
who's a precursor to the idea of Satan.
And then you can tell by partly because the words are quite similar and he has a
terrible battle with set who's taken over the kingdom and is a terrible tyrant,
is killing everyone and everything's going to hell.
And he has a battle with him to regain control of his kingdom.
And that's fine.
And he's a God.
And so as Seth and they have a fight and it's a terrible fight,
and during the fight,
Seth tares out one of his eyes.
When you think,
well,
that's a God,
right?
And nonetheless,
he ends up with his vision damaged,
his consciousness damaged.
Now he gains a different kind of sight.
He gains insight,
right?
Because now he knows the nature of evil,
but he pays a big price for it.
And so you think,
well,
if that's the case for God,
how much more is it the case for a man to be damaged?
It's like absolutely right.
It's no joke to encounter malevolence.
And I've seen that in my clinical clients too.
I had a client who was terrified into nightly convulsions for four years by the
look on her boyfriend's face when he attacked her.
It took me a long time to unpack that.
It was like a three month process,
but it was the,
it was,
see,
she was very naive,
very,
very naive because her parents had raised her in a world where the evil queen
was not allowed to visit like the parents and sleeping beauty.
So she was way too sheltered and she thought that human beings were only good,
you know?
And then she saw the look on his face that indicated that he was out to
consciously harm her and he,
he couldn't,
they had a fight,
a physical fight,
and she was strong enough to,
to prevail.
He wasn't that big,
but that wasn't the point is shattered her world because she didn't understand
until that point that someone could actually consciously want to hurt you.
You know,
that that wasn't just,
they weren't just in a bad mood and it wasn't just because of the way they were
raised.
And you know,
all those excuses that people come up that he was not only going to hurt her,
but he was going to enjoy it.
And if you don't understand the part of you that's capable of that,
then well you're,
you're,
uh,
dangerously,
dangerously naive and dangerous as well because you don't know what you're
capable of.
So
a lot of these things that you bring up are about leadership and,
and you know,
I talk about leadership all the time and one of the things that,
you know,
I heard you say,
um,
and you've talked about with,
with chimpanzees and other hierarchies that are out there,
including lobsters,
which I know you like quite a bit.
Uh,
and you know,
even lobsters have a,
a dominance hierarchy,
which is,
which is definitely incredible since how big is their brain?
It's not like it's mostly distributed through their bodies.
I mean,
it's not that big.
And Yeah,
it is absolutely unbelievable to,
to know that the hierarchical arrangement,
like it's a,
the reason it's a symbolic reality.
So that would be the great father.
Let's say.
The reason that's a symbolic reality is because he can't see a hierarchy.
Like if you look at the world,
it's,
you don't see a hierarchy.
But chimps know exactly where each chimp is in the hierarchy.
So for example,
a,
a low ranking,
mature chimp won't attack a high ranking juvenile even though he could tear them
apart because he knows that that juvenile is actually an illusion.
The juveniles juvenile plus all the other chimps that will come to his rescue,
right?
So he can't perceive the hierarchy with his eyes,
but he can perceive the hierarchy with his emotions.
Okay.
So that hierarchy is essentially eternal.
It's at least 350 million years old and it's,
and we perceive that all the time.
We look at hierarchical posturing,
we look at we and we live in hierarchies of competence mostly.
So that's,
that's a,
that's a universal truth.
And the fact that you have to struggle with the fact of the hierarchy is also
universal truth that you actually see this being played out to some degree in
the leftist feminist arena.
Because really what's happening is they,
they look at the hierarchy,
let's say the male hierarchy,
they don't attribute it to it
competence.
They attribute to it power and they make the presupposition that you get to the
top by being the meanest,
most exploitive creature possible.
And so these are often damaged women who've never had a good relationship with
Matt,
with a man and who can't distinguish between competence and power.
There's a big difference because a hierarchy that's only based on power is a
tyranny.
But a hierarchy based on competence is something that gets things done.
Like not exactly what you want in a hierarchies that the competent people climb
the hierarchy.
So you can tell who's competent out the top and you,
you made reference to the chimpanzee work.
I mean friends to wall has showed quite clearly that unstable chimp power
hierarchies are based on territory.
So it is that the ugliest,
meanest brute of the chimp gets to the top.
But like as soon as he has a bad day,
then two,
three quarter as strong chimps tear them into pieces and the chimps that manage
to maintain power at the top,
or let's say authority,
because that's a better word,
cause we gotta get her words right.
That's a chimp that has friends.
And that engages in reciprocal grooming and that pays reasonable attention to
the females.
And so it's so interesting to see that because it shows that even at that level
of biological organization,
there's already a morality of leadership.
Yeah.
And that was where,
that strikes me as so interesting.
And I try to explain this to people all the time because,
well,
in the seal teams,
again,
you,
you might think the same thing.
Well,
the biggest,
toughest seal that can destroy everyone else is going to be the leader that
everyone looks to.
And it's just not true.
And in fact,
a lot of times those guys that might be the biggest and the strongest and the
fastest,
they're,
they're actually arrogant as well because they've,
they think they can beat everyone and no one wants to work for those people.
And so,
uh,
it happened when I first started my consulting business and,
and I would have,
you know,
a CEO say,
I can't wait til you come in and just whip my people into shape.
And I'd say,
well,
you need to find somebody else that's going to whip people into shape because I
don't do that.
And they couldn't quite put together that me would,W wasn't into whipping people
into shape and know what I wanted to actually do is teach people to lead and to
lead people myself.
And when you're leading,
you're not having to whip people.
In fact,
that's an indication that you're not leading.
Exactly that as a leader,
where I,
the the place where I usually found myself was I'm actually having to pull the
reigns back on people because they're,
they're going far and away above what I actually would even want and expect them
to do.
They want to go even more than do more to accomplish the mission.
Then that's where you want to get.
And I find it interesting that,
you know,
you talk about that all the time,
that it's,
that it's not the person with the biggest club.
It's not the person that's the meanest and the most aggressive.
Sure,
they might,
they might rise for a minute,
they might get some control.
And that happens in any organization.
Oh,
if you've got a CEO that really,
he's just a tyrant and everyone's scared of him,
he can make some things happen for a little while and then all of a sudden
someone says,
I'm,
oh,
he wants us to do it that way.
I'm going to do a little sabotage.
Right?
Just a little sabotage your project that you want us to get done by October 31st
oh it got delayed boss.
And you can go nuts and you can yell and scream,
but you should have listened to me when I said we needed more time and now guess
where we are.
We didn't deliver the product we were supposed to deliver.
So you can yell and scream all you want.
It's not going to get that product delivered
well in a few Tierra.
Nice people badly enough,
they'll actually hurt themselves to hurt you.
So,
you know,
they're willing to take a,
they'll willing to take a hit to,
to reclaim justice,
let's say.
So yeah,
that's really worth knowing.
And so one of the things that John Piaget pointed out and cause he was,
he's a very interesting psychologist and,
and,
and he's never taught properly because you know,
most of these great thinkers were very strange people and the strangeness Gets
Edited Out of their stories.
And it's really too bad because they're way more interesting when you know how
strange they were.
And so Piaget was obsessed with the disjunction between religion and science.
And his goal as a thinker was to reconcile the two.
And so to some degree he was looking for a biological basis of morality.
That might be one way of thinking about it,
or at least to reconcile the idea of a biological substrate with an emergent
morality.
And one of the things he said is,
okay,
imagine two systems.
All right?
So both systems are moving towards a goal,
any old arbitrary goal and in one system,
the,
the people within interacting under compulsion and in the other system that
people within it are acting voluntarily said the people who are acting
voluntarily will defeat the people acting under compulsion.
Because in order to use compulsion,
you have to spend a fair bit of time and energy force.
And so it makes you inefficient.
Whereas if everybody is together on the project,
then they'll,
you don't have to spend any time on compulsion because people are compelling
themselves.
And so that's what he called an equilibrated state.
So nyquil [inaudible] state was,
well,
we sit down and we have a negotiation.
It's a real negotiation.
So it,
it has to be honest and we say,
okay,
well what the hell are we doing?
And everyone hashes that out and we decide what we're doing and then we decide
how that would be good for all of us.
But each of us singularly as well.
So if you got your family put together properly,
then the whole family moves together.
But everybody inside moves ahead as well.
And so then everybody's pushing in the same,
you know,
you know how it is within,
in a negotiation,
you actually want your interests to align with the interests of the other person
because then you don't have to worry about the integrity of the deal.
It's like everybody has reasons to keep it,
to keep it thriving.
And the idea that capitalism in somehow is somehow is predicated on the tyranny
of the people at the,
at the pinnacle that happens when it gets corrupt,
but it doesn't happen at all when it's working properly because deals that
aren't based on mutual self interest and group interest simultaneously have to
be enforced usually with lawyers and then you're done,
right?
You're done at that point.
That's,
that's actually incredible.
So I would,
when I worked with companies,
everyone's working with a company is a couple of years ago,
maybe even three or four years ago,
and you know,
they were talking about how they needed to hold their salespeople accountable
and that's what they needed to do.
And they needed more accountability in the sales leadership underneath them,
needed to hold all their frontline sales leaders accountable for everything and
follow these rules and make these numbers of calls and do these follow up things
and send the followup emails and they need to get this accountability thing
going.
And this was the when,
when I heard this guy saying,
this was the first time I said,
because I'd heard this a lot.
This is word accountability and leadership.
You hear,
oh well we just need better accountability,
better accountability.
And it's a trick because you think about it and you say to yourself,
well,
if I'm in charge of you guys and I'm going to hold you accountable to make sure
you do everything you're supposed to do,
well then we will successfully do what it is you,
you will do.
Because I held you accountable.
I made you do it.
The problem is,
in any organization,
there's too many people to hold everyone accountable to everything that they're
supposed to be doing.
So it just doesn't work.
And so you could take one group,
and this is what I said to him,
I said,
if you've got one group where you have to hold them accountable for each and
everything that you do and you and you try and do that versus a group where
people know what they're supposed to do and they want to go and do it,
I go,
which,
which team is gonna win?
And he said,
well,
a group that wants to do them.
So I was like,
oh,
that's what you need to do is get them to want to do with them.
So that's leadership too.
Well,
exactly the exact same thing you just described.
Exactly.
Right.
Yep.
I
mean,
look,
if you get people to track everything they do,
it takes them longer to track and then to do it.
Plus they hate it.
They hate it because they're not being trusted and it's the most terrible,
dull administrative work.
And it just kills people who are actually productive because they're driven
crazy by that.
It's,
leave me the hell alone so I can do my work.
You know?
And so,
yeah.
So,
so there,
there's something that,
here's an interesting little fact that,
that I think is really cool.
I found this out.
This is from the psychological literature.
So I'd been interested in how to increase people's motivation for a long time,
you know,
and um,
and there's a nice literature on that and,
and part of it was as was created by a late late them and lock carry late them
and Edwin Locke.
And they are looking at goal setting.
That's how they described it as a means to improve business productivity.
And so what they imagine that you have two teams and you get them to set goals,
say,
and one team sets goals for their corporate productivity and another team sets
goals for their life and then you match them head to head over some period of
time and see which one comes up ahead.
And what happens is that the people who set goals for their life beat the people
who set goals for the company.
And so that's free.
And then there's a variety of other literatures that support that kind of
hypothesis.
But it's,
it's a very,
very worthwhile thinking that through because what you want,
if your company is structured properly,
he want people in it who have a life,
right?
So they're aiming at things that they think are valuable because they're just
not going to be motivated,
period.
Unless they're aiming at things they think are valuable.
And then you want their loyalty to the company to be nested inside that.
So they have to see that working there,
no matter what it is that they're doing.
And,
and you know,
often jobs are repetitive and Dell and difficult and,
and challenging and all of that,
or you wouldn't be paid to do them,
right?
They're not all fun and games.
Um,
but if you can see that the less intrinsically interesting things that you're
required to do are related in some directly intelligible way to goals that you
regard as valuable,
then that tags those activities with this dopaminergic kick that we were talking
about earlier.
So you need this hierarchy of values,
right?
Just like,
here's what I'm doing with my life.
Here's why my job is important to that.
Or maybe it isn't.
And then you have to quit and go find a new job.
But that's fine.
But you know,
cause you might discover that too.
And so we started,
um,
trying to formalize this when at the same time that I also realized something
that I've never recovered from realizing I think.
So I teach students usually for this class,
it was third and fourth year students.
And so this is at the University of Toronto.
They're pretty smart kids.
It's a hard university to get into and they're pretty disciplined and they're
actually quite conservative,
all things considered.
And uh,
I was teaching them about stories and about the fact that our life is a story
with a goal and a purpose and a beginning point.
And,
and,
um,
I was encouraging them to develop their own stories.
So I had them write an autobiography and they really got into that.
That was quite amazing to identify,
you know,
to break their life into eat parks and then to describe the important episodes
in each epoch,
both positive and negative and what they might do to reduce the possibility of
the negative in the future and to capitalize on the positive,
which is the purpose of memory,
by the way.
And then also to write a plan for the future.
And so we s we formalize that.
So the plan is okay,
first of all,
you have to get yourself in the right mindset and the mindset is you're trying
to take care of yourself like you would care for someone that you cared for.
That's a hard mindset to get into because people like their pets better than
they liked themselves often.
And then you have to have a vision and so the vision would be,
well,
okay,
three to five years down the road,
if your friendship networks were configured properly,
what would that look like?
If you were pursuing the career that would be appropriate for you and sustaining
for you,
what would that look like?
How are you going to educate yourself?
How are you going to take care of yourself mentally and physically?
What do you want for an intimate relationship?
And how are you going to handle temptations like alcohol and drug abuse?
Cause they take people down pretty frequently.
So all you have to do is think about,
okay,
what could that be like if you had what you needed,
not some wild fantasy but,
but realistic in what you needed.
So that's the first part.
And then,
okay,
now write for 20 minutes about what your life could be like three to five years
down the road if all of this came together.
And then now do the opposite.
So imagine all your weaknesses and all the ways that you can go down the wrong
path.
And then imagine that gets the upper hand.
Then imagine where you are in three to five years.
So then you get a polarity,
a,
it's like not this and that.
And yes,
this.
So you can run away from the things you don't want and you can run towards the
things you do want.
That gets your anxiety behind you instead of in front of you.
Right?
Because maybe you're going to go do something difficult and you're afraid of it.
And then you think,
well,
if I don't do this,
I'm going to end up there.
It's like,
oh,
okay,
that's so terrible that this little terrible is nothing.
So,
and then in the next part of the exercise,
you turn that into an implementable plan,
you know,
and you write about why your life would be better and why your family's life
would be better and while your community's life would be better.
So it's like fully articulated and we've tested about 10,000 university students
with that now in three different locales and we've increased the probability
that they'll stay in university by about 30% and raised their grade point
average about the same.
And it's worked best for men who are most,
who were doing the least well.
So in Holland,
those word nonwestern ethnic minority men and they improve their port
performance enough to actually slightly exceed the Dutch national women who are
at the top otherwise over two years.
Yeah,
it was unbelievable.
It just blew us away.
Psychological intervention to cure in hypothetically
a sociological problem.
And so and so that,
that's a good example of how,
and it did what blew me away when I was first considering this as I had all
these students,
21 years old and I realized that no one had ever sat them down,
not even once in their entire career in education and said,
okay,
who do you want to be like,
what sort of person is it that you want to be?
Not,
not job.
It's like character.
What do you want your life to be like?
What should it be like and what shouldn't it be like?
And like write about that seriously,
like your life depends on it because it does.
And,
and then I thought,
well that's so weird.
Why in the world isn't our education system set up to help people with that?
Cause it's like that's kind of obvious,
you know,
it's like,
what are you doing and why?
And then I did some reading partly from John Gatto whose done some interesting
work looking at the history of the education system.
And it was a derivation of the Prussian education system back in the late 18
hundreds and it was designed to produce obedient,
obedient,
well it was partly soldiers,
but it was partly workers.
Oh I was going to say it definitely with soldiers.
Cause that was the transition when they,
they had the transition take place at that time as well,
where they moved away from centralized command to after they got beat by
Napoleon and they never,
they were constantly trying to fight towards that direction where the soldiers
would not just be obedient because they realize that that is not what they
actually wanted.
They don't,
they finally started to do at the end of World War One and,
and if they would've done it earlier,
it might have turned the tide of the war.
But that was what,
you know,
that's what World War II,
the blitzkrieg and,
and total decentralized command and elements just going out and making things
happen and finding gaps in the defenses and attacking them as opposed to you're
just gonna wait until you're told what to do.
Right.
And that was the,
the German way and decentralized command.
Well,
a competence beats obedience,
right?
So you unite people under a goal and then you let them act autonomously.
You got to get them,
you got to not sell them the goal.
That's not right.
You know,
what you have to do is you have to go in and talk to them and discover what the
goal is of the enterprise and what it is that fires people up.
And that really does work,
you know,
and the idea that capitalism is essentially crooked and it's the people who are,
who are pulling the wool over other people's eyes who when it's like,
well,
you know,
now and then there's a criminal action and the person gets away with it,
so to speak.
Although people get away with a lot less than they think,
but most of the time within a functional company,
you better have your people on board or they will do exactly what you said
they'll do.
They'll spend 80% of their time sabotaging the company.
Yeah.
And I,
again,
something I learned working with a corporate world and it was working with a
corporate world where I reflected on what I did.
And,
and it was talking to a a leader or business leader at some point.
And I said,
well,
you know,
your people can understand why they're doing what they're doing.
And so when he absorbs that and says,
okay,
that's makes sense.
And so then he gets up in front of his team and he says,
you know,
well the reason why we're doing this,
this is we want to improve our profitability as a company.
And you know,
he sat down and we talked afterwards and you said,
did I,
did I do good job?
Because now they understand that I said,
oh no,
actually doing cubist it.
And then I started explaining to them better because I learned that what you
have to explain,
there has to be a thread of why that goes all the way through the corporate
reason.
But that why it has to come back down to the individual contributor.
So they realize that when,
when we do better as a company,
when we're more profitable as a company,
we can put more money in art,
in marketing,
and we can produce stuff cheaper because we'll do it on a more mass scale,
then we can lower prices and then we can actually hire more people.
And that's going to make you move up in this command here and you're gonna make
more money.
We're going to sell more stuff and you're going to get a bigger bonus.
So you doing this,
the reason why you're doing it just because then you can achieve those life
lessons because you want to buy that house,
that car and send your kid to school.
So there's a big difference.
You need to make sure that the people understand why they're doing it,
not for the corporate reason,
not for the mission reason,
but for,
for why it's going to help them.
The exact same thing you just said.
It's also really helpful too if you,
you know,
your corporation has,
I hate to use the word vision because that's,
you know,
it turned into a Buzzword,
but you know,
it's often that you're working in a company where worthwhile things are
happening,
exciting and worthwhile things you know,
and you're,
you're,
you're trying to well make something better at a lower price,
let's say.
And so there's the,
the,
the heroism,
let's say,
of producing a product that's going to have a positive impact on the world and
you need to know how your small actions are tied with that greater goal.
And then there's this financial self interest as well.
And,
and the thing is,
if you don't,
if you can't tell your workers that story,
then either your company is fundamentally corrupt because that isn't the true
story.
It's like you're actually working so that I can rape and pillage the company
over the next four years and take all the value out of it and run.
Because you know,
CEOs do that from time to time.
Yes.
Or you don't understand how the company works and you can't tell the story,
which means you're basically and competent.
So,
but well,
people are not wired up so that they will work without knowing why unless you
beat them.
And then if you beat them,
you don't.
Don't be thinking that that's victory.
So it's a temporary victory.
It's,
that's also something really good to know about marriage.
It's like you can never win an argument with your wife.
Like you could if you only lived with her for one day.
Right?
It's like I one see you later.
It's like,
no,
she's there the next day.
And then she's been,
she remembers that.
She does.
She does remember that.
Yeah.
Maybe even more than you remember it.
You know?
And it also might be that she was right and you just out argued her.
So you know,
and that's something that's really worth knowing too,
because sometimes you know,
you'll have an argument with,
well let's say with your wife,
and she's got something to say and it's not very well articulated.
Same could be true for you.
And so you can just brush it aside.
But you don't want to brush it aside because maybe there's something there and
if you don't address it,
then it's not like it's going to go away,
man.
It's going to grow.
So maybe you have to help her formulate her argument,
which is really annoying cause you want to win.
You have in this dispute like I want to win.
It's like,
well,
you're not winning that game.
You're winning the game.
Well,
I think about it as the game of games.
You want to win the set of games that stretch across time,
the long war.
Yeah,
that's right.
Exactly
the long that little battles knocked,
no matter.
And in fact,
I don't,
you should not try and be right.
If you're right,
everybody knows it's fine,
but there's the worst thing.
Rub It in and say I'm right and you're wrong.
Yeah,
yeah.
You do that a hundred times and then like,
well,
you're the,
you're the winner and she's the loser and then that's great because now you're
married to a loser.
I mean,
you know,
that's,
if you do that 100,000 times,
then your marriage is over and then,
and then there'll be hell to pay.
You can be sure of that.
I got asked the other day,
um,
what is the biggest problem in America?
And I thought about it,
I hadn't been asked that question lately.
I've been getting some good questions.
A lot of times like you,
I get the same questions over and over and over again,
but I got to ask what's the biggest problem in America?
And I thought about it for a second,
and this may or may not be right,
but I thought it was at least thought provoking.
I said that the biggest problem that we have in America is that we don't have
any big problems.
And if you look at us in World War Two during the depression,
during times where we've got major,
major problems,
the country kind of unifies and it,
and it gets behind itself and joins together.
And you know,
I,
I talked about,
you know,
that we,
we,
we live in a bubble here.
I kind of opened up with that as well.
And,
and that's good.
Like I want there to be a bubble just like I want my family to live in a bubble
and I almost want,
I almost want my daughter to really,
really think it's a real problem that there's not a strong wifi signal in her
bedroom.
And so sometimes it takes longer to do.
I,
I've kind of succeeded as a dad if that's her problem,
if she sees that as a problem that,
you know,
it takes a little extra.
There's a,
there's a longer buffering time on some of her Netflix,
right?
I've done a good job if that's a problem because you know,
God can only imagine what kind of problems people really have.
But sometimes I feel like in America and really in the West as a whole,
the problem is,
is that we don't have any major problems.
So now it's the Wifi in our bedroom.
We're getting crazy about and,
and,
and wanting to lash out about.
And I guess my point here is that do we as individuals,
do we need to struggle there to keep us focused on the right things and as a
country or as a culture,
do we need to have some level of struggle before we start looking at things that
don't matter and turning them into things that we perceive as actually
mattering?
Yeah.
Well you know a couple of things about that.
Kierkegaard wrote about that back in the late 1850s there abouts and he said
there will come a time when the best thing that you could do for people would be
to make things more difficult.
Right.
And that's the thing because everyone's working so hard and making things
easier.
That will be,
they'll come a time when there's a felt sense for difficulty.
And I think we're at that point now.
And I think that that's why this message of responsibility and truth is echoing
so nicely among,
particularly among young men.
Cause every time I talk about that in my public talks,
the room goes silent.
And that's really interesting.
And you know,
people are dead focused on it.
And so like enough rights and freedom.
It's like truth and risk,
low time for truth and responsibility.
And there's something noble about that and we haven't been able to talk about no
ability for God only knows how long,
you know.
So I do think that's the case and I think it's a I and W and William James said
that what we need is a moral equivalent to war.
So something that's as serious,
but that is hopefully not as destructive.
And so I really liked that idea as well.
And so,
but I think that we are at that cake at that point,
if people would open their eyes a little bit because we have this unbelievable
culture,
this technological culture that does provide the degree of protection that you
described,
that's an ongoing miracle,
right?
It's absolutely unbelievable that any of this works at all.
And it could easily not work.
And if it didn't work,
there would be hell to pay and,
and to keep it working and to keep it moving forward,
especially with what's going to come over the next 10 years with,
with,
with artificial intelligence and the sorts of things that we're,
we're learning and inventing.
We better have our acts together.
And so I think that you can get that warlike sense if you start to,
if you start to understand that you can take on your life like that.
That's also why I think it's so necessary to see the world as a battleground in
some sense between good and evil.
But you don't put the evil outside.
Like some of it's outside obviously,
but that's not your initial concern.
Your initial concern is to get your act together right,
to take on the burden of being,
to bear the suffering.
Like you said,
you found that when you went out into combat that you know,
you might've been wary of death,
which is perfectly reasonable,
but that you weren't afraid of it to the point where it would paralyze you.
Well that's a useful thing to know,
you know,
because it means that you're
different than you thought you were.
You know,
because people are afraid of suffering and death and especially if they've been
completely and constantly sheltered from it.
But you can discover,
and lots of people do that if they actually confronted that they can tolerate it
far better than they thought.
I mean,
think about all the people who work in like palliative care wards,
you know,
or in funeral parlors for that matter,
like they're confronting death on an ongoing basis and yet every day they go to
work.
So people are tough.
And so I think there is a responsibility that everybody can take up.
And I think the responsibility is something like,
well,
we need to decide if we're going to collectively and individually tilt the world
towards heaven are tilted towards hell.
We saw what hell was like in the 20th century.
I could be back at our doorstep in no time flat and we should have learned that.
And it's necessary for people to understand the relationship between their
individual actions and the direction of culture as a whole.
You know,
look at that guy in charge of Charlottesville,
you know,
that was one guy and he probably increased polarization in the United States by
like 5% or something.
You know,
it doesn't take very many individual actions of that pathological sort to tip
things in a very terrible direction.
So one of the things I've been telling the people who've been watching my videos
and in the live conversations is that you have to take yourself seriously.
You have to know that you're a monster and that you're capable of terrible
things and that it's,
and that you have a responsibility to understand that,
to incorporate it,
to constrain it and to discipline it.
And then to work for the alleviation of suffering and the constraint of
malevolence.
And if you understand that,
then it can turn your life into a noble enterprise and then you have some self
respect,
which beats the hell out of self esteem in my estimation.
So,
and I don't think that that's a difficult message for people to understand.
I think they know that at a fundamental level.
And I think at the moment they're starving to death for it.
The
subordinate principles.
So the,
the,
the thing
when you talk about this elevated state,
this elevated thing,
I think I've figured out that what you're talking about is essentially truth.
That is that to you sort of the,
what we need to do is deal in truth on a daily basis in our own lives and,
and in the lives with people around us.
Well I think it's two things like in,
in a,
in,
in sort of classical Christian morality.
And I bring it up cause it's sort of at this substructure of Western ethics,
there's two things.
There's truth and love and,
and you know both of those words or even hard to say because they'd be mouth to
death but,
but they have in some sense they have a deep technical meeting and if you know
that,
then it kind of reignites their power and love is the decision that being is
worthwhile and should and that you should struggle to support and improve it.
And that's not a trivial thing because being is rife with suffering and I,
everyone dies,
everyone gets sick.
Like,
it's,
it's brutal,
it's brutal and it's easy to turn against it.
And so the idea that you're going to voluntarily accept responsibility for that,
assume that it's good or act as if it's good and try to improve it.
It's no trivial matter.
And that means you have to scour out the resentment and the arrogance and the
deceit.
And primarily,
and,
and it's sort of based on this idea I would say is like,
well,
life is very hard obviously,
but we're not doing everything we could to make it better.
And we're often doing things to make it worse.
So even if it is suffering,
which is true,
we have no idea how much we could ameliorate that if we all put our efforts into
it.
And so that's a genuine question.
It's like,
yeah,
there's reasons to shake your fist and curse God.
I mean,
everyone ends up in a situation like that.
Someone they love gets a terrible illness and disintegrates before their eyes,
you know,
and maybe they're a really good person and they've done nothing you would think
of to deserve that.
And you know that terrible fate is visited upon them.
It's very difficult not to get cynical and angry under such circumstances.
But then while that takes you down a very bad road if you do that,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't,
it doesn't change the fundamental question.
It's like if your life isn't everything you think it should be,
you have to ask yourself if you're doing everything you can because you actually
don't get to make a judgment about the structure of being until you do
everything you can.
And I would say that's love.
Essentially that's the decision.
And then truth is the best,
the best strategy with regards to that attainment and how could it be otherwise.
Like if you're going to contend with reality,
you bloody well better know what it is.
In truth isn't your grandmothers,
you know,
you're,
you're too tight laced grandmothers moral finger wagging.
It's like the truth of existence is brutal and bitter.
And so to be able to face that and to admit to the things that you are and to,
and to communicate them with other people,
especially in an intimate relationship,
it's like that's,
that's no cowardly morality.
That's not the morality of cowardice.
Quite the contrary.
You know,
Nisha said you could assess the spirit of a man by determining how much truth he
can tolerate.
It's like that's,
that's the right,
that's the right way of thinking about truth.
Well,
you opened this whole podcast with some truth.
It's like,
who wants to hear that?
You know,
and people think,
oh,
that's so terrible.
And they don't think,
well,
could I be one of those isis guys?
It's like I can tell you if you're bitter enough,
especially if you hate women,
you know,
cause they've rejected you because you're such a so goddamn useless that no
woman in their right mind would look at you twice.
You know,
that'll generate plenty of bitterness in your soul.
And if you don't think that you could act like that under those conditions,
then you're not even watching your own fantasies.
So
truth in the service of the betterment of being.
It's something like that and that's,
that's enough to give your life.
Meaning I don't care where you start.
Like I had this kid come and visit me while back and he had never left his home
state and he was,
I think he was 19 and he was overprotected and over sheltered and he was a smart
kid.
And so of course he also thought that the world really hadn't appreciated his
gifts,
which is very common feeling for smart kids who,
who aren't getting anywhere.
Right.
They get really angry about that.
And then he decided that he was going to move out of his house and he took a job
as a dishwasher and he said he tried to do a good job as a dishwasher.
It's like good.
That's some humility.
It's just a dishwashing job,
but you know,
you can be a good dishwasher and then the restaurant runs better and then it's
kind of fun.
As long as the people you're working with are half decent,
you can make good social relationships and then you can learn to be social which
was happening to him.
And then maybe they let you be a short order cook,
you know,
and you got a bit of a clue and then you have a bit of money and you have a
little independence and it's a lot better than being at home and being bitter
and resentful and immature.
You know,
it's just a dishwashing job.
Well that's the wrong way of thinking about it.
It's like it's,
it's the first door that's open to you,
you know,
and then he came up to Toronto,
he had never been out of his home state so it was a big deal for him to come to
another city.
And when he first came to talk to me,
it was outside of one of my lectures.
He couldn't even speak.
He was so nervous cause he had pretty high levels of social anxiety.
So it was tongue tied and I invited him to come over to my house to talk to him
cause I knew there was something up with him and he told me the story,
you know,
and I thought,
well you know,
that's the beginnings of a heroic journey.
He was able to humble himself enough so that you know,
if you're low,
if you're in a low place,
it's a low door that's going to open and you might think I'm too high to crawl
through that low door.
Young said,
Carl Jung said people,
modern people don't see God cause they don't look low enough.
I really liked that idea,
but that's it.
If you're in a low place,
the opportunity that presents itself to you is going to be low and it's going to
be very tempting to you cause you're arrogant,
resentful to say,
well that's not good enough for me.
It's like,
well do you have an alternative?
If you don't have an alternative,
then an in shop is up and it's the right trajectory.
You know?
And so that's humility.
That's humility.
It's like you're low,
you take what you take,
what's given to you and you see if you can make it work.
And the thing is that works way faster than people think.
Even because I worked as a dishwasher when I was a kid,
you know,
for you for a year or so.
And it was really hard to begin with because I didn't know what I was doing in
the German chef who is kind of a tough guy,
just let me flounder around for two weeks to see if I would quit.
So I was there till like three in the morning and I was 13 I think.
I couldn't wash all these damn dishes.
I thought it was impossible.
I told my dad at one point,
I said,
I don't know if I can do this.
It's like I'm working as hard as I can and they keep piling up,
you know?
But I didn't stop.
And then the German cook,
you know,
who had been treating me pretty harshly at one day he said,
okay,
I'll show you how to do this.
And then he showed me how to organize the dishes and everything.
And it was like,
that was not no problem,
I can do it.
And like 10% of the time.
So then I cleaned up the rest of the kitchen and I had a good time mark and boat
with the chefs and we played around a lot back there.
And I ended up working as a short order cook and I learned to cook and all of
that.
And that was a good part of my adolescence.
But,
but the thing is,
so the thing is,
is that those trivial jobs,
it's the conception of their triviality that makes them trivial.
They're not trivial,
not if you do them right.
And if you're around people who have any sense,
you know,
sensible people are always looking around for other people who can do things
right.
And if they see you trying to do things right,
the probability that they'll open a door for you is virtually 100% cause it's
kind of rare,
you know,
so they're going to be skeptical to begin with to see,
you've got to prove your mettle,
let's say.
But as soon as you do,
they'll think,
okay,
well we'll give this kid a little bit more opportunity and see what happens.
And you know,
to not think that's how the world works is to be extraordinarily cynical because
that is how it works in,
in a functioning society.
I mean I work with businesses all the time and there is the they,
anybody that is just above normal competency in anything,
even that that's going to try it.
I mean that's going to put effort in.
They,
they love those people and those people are going to do well and you're
absolutely right.
The doors are absolutely going to open for them if they do what they're trying
to do to the best of their ability and doing a competent job at it.
Well the other thing that's interesting is what happens to people who aren't
trying because what happens to them is like they're in a place where there's a
thousand doors in front of them that are invisible.
They don't know the doors are there and they could either be opened or closed.
And so if they're one of these people who is going above and beyond the call of
duty,
unless the organization is entirely corrupt,
right?
And that happens sometimes.
Then there are people who are watching and they'll start to open these invisible
doors and then all of a sudden the person has opportunities in front of them and
they don't even know why some of the time,
right?
Because someone said,
you know,
gave a positive word to someone else and said,
well,
you could take a look at this kid.
And,
and so these doors open.
And then the people who are in their grudgingly and bitterly,
it's like people watch that and they're the people who are the gatekeepers and
they just closed the doors and then the person looks up and there's nothing in
front of them.
There's no open doors at all.
And they,
and then,
then they curse God,
you know,
for making such a miserable cosmos.
It's like,
no,
you just don't understand what you just don't understand.
What happened is like the fruits of your bitterness,
your bitterness manifested fruit.
You don't even know it.
You've delimited your options in a terrible way and you've closed,
you know,
you're,
you're walking down,
you're walking between cliff walls and they're getting closer and closer and
closer together,
and then you'll be stuck and you'll think,
how the hell did this happen?
And it happened because
you didn't,
you didn't avail yourself of the opportunities that presented themselves to you.
So,
you know,
that's horrible.
But that's,
that's how it is.
I get asked a quite often,
um,
you know,
this guy got promoted and I should have gotten promoted.
What should I do now?
Or this person isn't carrying their load and,
and,
and they're,
they think I should do their work.
What should I do now?
And you know the answers.
Yeah.
Something,
someone wants you to do their work.
Do they want to do the work?
Yes.
I'll do that all day long.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you don't want to do your job.
That's fine.
I'll do it.
And actually I got,
I just answered a question where somebody said,
today,
the guy's a friend of mine and he's not carrying as load.
What should I do?
And I said,
well,
how about you help him?
What's going on at home?
Or is he going through a divorce as he got issues,
kids sick?
How about you help them and say,
Hey,
let me,
let me take that off your plate right now because it two months or six months,
you might be the person that needs help.
You might be the person with a sick child,
but regardless of that,
maybe he's just is lazy and maybe he shouldn't be your front and maybe
eventually you won't be your friend.
But nonetheless,
the solution is the same.
If you don't want to do your work,
that's fine.
I'll do it.
That's such a funny,
funny thing.
That's exactly right.
Because you know what you want to do and in your job is make yourself
indispensable.
Right?
And the way you make yourself indispensable is by being indispensable.
And the way you do that is by doing a bunch of things that if they're not done,
catastrophe occurs.
And that's exactly right.
So if there's someone around you and they're abdicating your their
responsibility and you can pick it up,
it's like what an opportunity.
You know,
it's,
you think,
well,
I'm not going to get credit for it.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
there's lots of different forms of credit,
but you learn.
And then when the company shrinks and they're looking at who to keep,
you know,
they think,
oh,
it turns out you're doing all sorts of,
so we can't do without you.
That's not what we expected.
We can't do without you.
Here's some more things you could do.
You know?
And then you're also in a position to bargain.
You can say,
well look,
you know,
um,
in order for me to keep doing this level of responsibility,
you know,
I needed to be paid more because I have other options or,
or because it's just,
or because that will make me more efficient.
But then you've got some power too,
because they need you.
And
so indispensability and that's power.
Indispensability as power,
not tyranny.
So now,
um,
obviously we started off talking about some very negative stuff with,
with Isis.
And you've touched on this a little bit already,
but I,
I want to make sure we hit this hard enough.
And that is for people to,
to live a better life,
to live a life that they're proud of,
to live a life that they,
that,
that when they die,
they don't regret the life that they lived.
And for me,
I mean,
I,
I tell people discipline equals freedom.
That the,
the hard work,
the doing the right thing.
Um,
you know,
I tell people to write down what you're supposed to do the next day before you
go to bed and then you wake up and do the things that you're supposed to do.
The things that you said you were supposed to do,
the things that you actually know are going to make you healthier and faster and
smarter and stronger and,
and make you more money and,
and move you forward and help your family.
You just write those things down and then you go do them.
And that's essentially,
you've drawn that out on a large scale with,
and you've described this somewhat with the experiment that you did with,
with people writing down what they're supposed to do,
not just tomorrow,
but what their life,
that's the future offering program.
And that's,
that's really,
um,
been immensely beneficial for people.
It certainly seems to have been.
Um,
it's that self authoring.com and we put up a discount code for your,
for your listeners.
It's willing,
um,
and so they can get 20% off it.
And it,
it,
this system allows you to write an autobiography and to analyze your personality
flaws and virtues and to write a future plan and you can do all of those are one
of them.
Um,
but yeah,
it's,
it's extremely useful because,
um,
one of the things you can be virtually certain of in life is that you don't get
something you don't aim at.
And one of the things that's interesting about that is often people will keep
their goals fuzzy because the,
one of the problems with specifying your goals as you specify your failures,
right?
If the goal is really fuzzy,
you're not sure when you fail and that then you can fool yourself,
you know,
really,
but you can kind of keep it foggy,
but you make your goal sharp and clear then well,
first of all,
then you know what to aim at.
And what's interesting is,
you know,
your brain is set up so that it reorganizes the world around your aims.
And that's not,
I've also written about this in 12 rules for life quite extensively.
And that's not a metaphor.
Like we don't see much of the world because there's a lot of the world and there
isn't much of us.
And so we see what we aim at,
we aim with our eyes.
And here's an example.
So a great apes don't really have much of a white in their eyes,
but human beings do.
And the reason for that is that we've evolved to detect where else is looking.
And so if I can't tell where you're looking,
I don't know what you're up to.
And then well over time that means I can't read you as well and we're more
likely to get in a dispute and one or the other of us is more likely to get
killed.
But it also means that your,
your probability of findings,
a successful mate decreases.
So we've evolved to have this very,
very visually evident.
I,
and so when we're looking at each other,
we're always looking at our,
ah,
our eyes because then we can tell where someone has pointed and then we can tell
what they're up to.
And so we're hunting creatures,
like we're aiming at a moving target and trying to track it all the time.
And so you have to specify your aim.
And the future authoring program helps people specify the Raymond.
It's,
it's more than one name.
It's like you have a highest aim,
which you might say is to be a good person.
And then I would say,
well there's a,
there's a more elaborated aim than that.
It's like you wanted to be able to constrain malevolence and work to decrease
suffering.
It's something like that.
That's the highest aim.
And,
and then,
and then you have to decompose that into the things you do each day so that
there's a definite connection between all the micro-actions and the macro aim.
And then that gives dignity to what you're doing,
you know?
So,
you know,
if your race at home with your kids,
what,
what are you trying to do?
Where you're trying to raise them to be the kind of moral agents that will work
to constrain the evil in the world and to reduce suffering.
It's like,
and so that's what you're doing when you're changing a diaper.
If you're doing it carefully and with some respect and some love,
like it's a major league deal to be doing that and God knows who your kid is
going to be.
You know,
he could be the kid that shoots up Columbine or it could be stolen.
That wouldn't be so good.
Or he could be someone or she could be someone who is a positive benefit to the
world,
you know?
And so every child is a whole new realm of,
of,
of possibilities.
And so there's dignity in that if you understand that.
So the future authoring program anyways helps people lay out a plan.
And I always suggest to people that they do it badly because you're not going to
do it perfectly.
And if you get perfectionistic,
it's going to stop you.
You know,
when you first start to plan,
you're probably only going to be about 20% right?
But zero,
the difference between zero and 20% is immense.
And we found with our research that even people who only spend an hour on it
benefits substantially in their ability to stick to what their next plan is now.
And you now,
you mentioned something earlier too,
just just a bit of Oh yes.
About about scheduling.
Yeah.
So one of the things I tell people,
so you say write down what you're going to do the next day before you go to bed.
That's good.
Because then you,
you've got a direction set when you wake up in the morning.
Hey,
so,
but I've told people to learn to use a schedule and people often hate schedules
because they act as their own tyrants,
right?
They say we have to do this unpleasant thing and then here's another unpleasant
thing you have to do.
And then you have to do this unpleasant thing and you do that for about three
days and you think tail with this,
I'm not doing that.
You know,
and you fall off the wagon.
That isn't what you're supposed to do with the schedule.
You're supposed to use it to design the days that you would like to have if you
were taking care of yourself.
And so some of that is,
you know,
you wake up in the morning and you think,
here's five things I have to do that if I don't do my life will be worse.
It's like paying bills for example,
or,
or taking out the garbage.
It's like you have to do those because otherwise things degenerate.
So you've got to put some of those in the schedule.
Cause otherwise tomorrow is worse than today.
And that's a bad trajectory.
But you also want to build in things.
You know,
you've got to act in some sense like you're dealing with a relatively
recalcitrant nine year old.
It's like so,
well here's some things you have to do.
But here's some things that if you do,
you could reward yourself with.
And if you get the balance there between obligation and reward,
right,
then you'll find that you're motivated to do the things.
And that's what you want to do.
You want to do that.
So it's sustainable across days and weeks and months.
And so you gotta,
you gotta treat yourself like a good boss would treat a valued employee and not
like a tyrant would treat a slave because the slave will rebel.
And you know,
people say,
well,
I don't follow through on my plans.
It's like,
well a,
they're probably not very well formulated and maybe you're doing them because of
an external moral obligation or something,
not really your plans,
right?
And B,
you're acting like a tyrant and a slave,
and that's a bad relationship to have with yourself.
So you want to treat yourself with some,
well,
the same way,
that's the golden rule,
right?
It treat yourself as you would treat other people as you would have them.
Sorry,
treat other people as you would like to be treated.
It works both ways.
You also treat yourself like you treat other people properly.
So that's a necessary thing.
And often people don't do that.
But the scheduling is really important.
Actually,
I,
when I tell people,
because when I first started talking about this,
people would start scheduling their day and they would just go,
you know,
minute by minute everything will be sculpted.
And you can't maintain that for multiple reasons.
Number one is no one wants to have a day like that where everything that you do
throughout the day,
minute to minute sucks.
It's things that you don't want to do.
So guess what?
After three days you say,
I'm not doing this anymore.
It's,
it sucks.
It's not fun.
And,
and so,
and the same thing with the task list.
People would push those off if they're not on the schedule.
So yeah,
I'd say put it on the schedule,
but then the thing I ended up telling people is,
you need to,
you need to number one,
schedule empty space in there where,
because things are going to take longer and then you're gonna be off scheduled.
Then you'll be frustrated.
So you scheduled that things are going to be just empty.
You're not going to do anything for,
for this hour before lunch.
You don't schedule anything.
You're not going to do anything.
You're not going to do anything there.
And the other thing is you schedule things that you actually want to do in there
and then you go and execute things that you want to do.
You want to work out every day,
you know you should,
well maybe,
maybe if it's something you enjoy,
then you schedule it in there.
If you enjoy going,
picking your kids up from school on Tuesdays and Thursdays because that's when
they do their running club,
then you schedule that in there so you can go and do that thing that you want to
do.
So you don't just schedule the things that suck.
You schedule the good things too.
And discipline equals freedom.
I say this all the time.
If you want to have more free time,
which is what people want,
then you need to have more discipline.
Time management,
you will end up with more free time.
I promise you.
I promise you you will.
The other thing I was thinking about and I,
I couldn't,
I,
I just kind of occurred to me now is people always tell people,
you know,
come up with a goal and then write it down and then you're going to get there.
And I was,
you know,
as you were talking about future authoring,
what you had said earlier when you were describing the program in its infancy,
what became future offering is I was saying,
well,
how do you get people to actually do this?
Well,
what's you've embedded in the program is the fear of what happens if you don't
do these things and where you're going to end up.
And people forget that people forget where they end up if they don't do what
they're supposed to do in life.
And I've explained this to my kids,
that when you look around and you see people that are doing things which are
self evidently not desirable things to be doing in life,
whether you're a bomb or whether you're doing a,
you know,
I was a dishwasher as well and I have an interesting story about that.
And I'll tell that at some point about a Scottish girl named Rosalind.
She was older than me.
I was 13 and after you know,
several weeks of washing dishes and she was like maybe 17 or 18 and and anyways,
to make a long story short,
eventually I said,
hey,
do you want to like go to a movie or something with me?
Cause I'd like to go to a movie with you.
And she looked at me and she said,
Jocko,
you have a serious mental problem.
So Roslyn,
I know you're out there somewhere.
You broke my heart sister,
but I washed dishes and that's a good thing for a 13 year old to do.
But when you're 18 okay,
now it's a little bit,
you want to have moved up to be the short order cook.
And by the time you're 25 you want to be in charge of the whole kitchen.
And by the time you're 30 you want to maybe run the nighttime shift and,
and that's a good progression.
And that's good.
What?
You don't want to be 35 and 40 40 years old out at the dishwashing stage.
You don't want to be there.
And I explained to my kids,
cause you can see people that are at that stage in their life and sure there's a
chance that maybe they had some hardship that came along that that that hit them
and it put them in this position and now they have to build back up again and
they're waiting for those windows of Harburg doors of opportunity to open up.
And that's okay.
But a lot of times it's because they didn't work,
they didn't make good decisions,
they didn't do the best job that they could.
And so they end up in these positions that they shouldn't be in.
And it's,
and I tell my kids that those are real people that are in those positions.
Like we're going to leave this restaurant and we're going to go home and we're
going to do what we do.
That guys going to be there for five
more hours because it's nine o'clock he's got to clean everything.
When they get done,
he's going to be there for five more hours.
Then he's got to mop the floor and you know what he's doing tomorrow.
The same thing he was doing the night after that.
The same thing.
It's a real person and I hope it's a 14 year old.
I hope it's a 16 year old.
I hope it's even an 18 year old,
but I hope it's not a 48 year old,
but there are 48 year olds that end up in that position.
And what you do in this program is you,
you explained that you can end up there and actually being a 48 year old
dishwasher is actually pretty positive too to where some of the Canada oh
definitely.
Which is addicted to drugs,
addicted to alcohol or,
or,
or whatever.
Well then everybody kind of has a sense of where they would end up if they let
things auger down,
you know,
and everybody has their,
their specific weaknesses that,
that their faults would exploit.
You know,
and some people would end up homeless and some people would end up with a
physical illness or a psychiatric illness and some people would end up addicted
and some people would end up cruel.
But everybody kind of knows where they would had,
cause they've seen it,
they've seen it rise up.
And it's really useful to be terrified of that as if it's a possibility,
you know,
that's a heaven and hell essentially.
It's like,
okay,
well how do you mean as if it's a possibility?
It's a possibility.
Yeah,
definitely.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
and,
and all you have to do to get there as do nothing.
I kill just drift there all by yourself.
So not only is it a possibility to actually rather high possibility,
and so you have to make that realistic enough,
which means that you have to take an inventory of your weaknesses.
Let's say.
You have to make that realistically enough so you're actually terrified of it
because then that's a great motivation.
And in my clinical practice,
people are often faced with tough decisions like,
well,
you know,
I'm not happy at my job and I'm afraid to leave it.
Fair enough.
You know?
That's a big deal.
Okay.
How afraid are you of not leaving it?
Let's lay that out.
Because you know,
one of the peculiarities of human thought is that you do get used to the devil,
you know,
and then you,
you downplay it,
but it's very often that's staying in the same place will do you in.
It's much worse than the risk that you'll take.
You know?
And I mean,
I'm practical with us.
I say,
look,
if you're going to stop your job,
let's,
let's have a clue about this,
right?
Get your CV together,
right.
Start seeing what other options you have because you don't want to just step off
a cliff that's not helpful.
Um,
organize yourself so that you've got enough strength to go through the process
of finding a new job.
You know,
you're going to have to get used to be an interview.
Do you got to think that through?
Maybe we can practice that.
So you've got to set yourself up for it,
but you really want to think through the cost of inaction.
And that's something people generally don't do.
And this is also one of the useful features of having a tragic view of life,
let's say.
Because most of the time,
often you're screwed either way,
but you get to pick which one and that's a big deal.
It's like there's,
there's risks on both paths and their major risks.
And that's actually freeing because you know,
well,
there's trouble both ways.
So that frees you up because if you think,
well,
this is the safe path and this is the dangerous path,
well then you're not going to take the dangerous path.
But if you think,
well,
I've got danger a or danger be,
and this is where I would rather bet my future,
while that's way better,
and I've had many,
many clients that I've helped with their careers and we do exactly doubt,
it's like,
you know,
okay,
what's our goal?
Our goal is to triple your salary in four years.
They think,
well that's not possible.
It's like,
well,
we'll try for doubling,
but you don't know it's possible.
You got to,
let's get it together and you've got to get over being afraid of looking for a
job.
You got to get over being afraid of being interviewed.
You have to put yourself together so that you've got options and then you got to
start to push.
You don't know you might be able to do it.
Well,
it's,
it's quite surprising how frequently that works,
you know?
And that assumes that people are trying,
right.
They're competent,
you know,
it's not,
this isn't me waving a magic wand or anything like that and it takes a lot of
work.
You know,
like if you're going to switch jobs,
you might have to,
I figure 50 to one failure to success.
It's something like that.
And it's useful to know the baselines as well,
right.
Because looking for a job is,
can be very disheartening unless you know the baselines.
It's like,
well yeah,
50 inch,
50 resumes for one interview.
Don't take it personally.
It's just how it is.
So it's not that you're a screw up,
it's that there are way more resumes than there are jobs and,
and,
um,
that can also,
and then,
you know,
don't look for a job for eight hours a day because you only be able to do that
for three days and then you'll die.
You look for a job an hour a day.
If you already have one for an hour a day or half an hour a day for three
months,
two resumes a day,
three resumes a day,
you'll find a job.
It'll take awhile.
I,
one of my clients took like three years,
you know,
to get her first break.
But then right after that she got another one and then right after that she got
another one.
But she stuck it out.
And you know,
it was brutal cause she had interviews and they didn't go,
you know,
they get the job that she didn't like at the time.
Yeah.
But I also say to people like,
you know,
generally stay in your job because you're way more likely to get a new job when
you have a job.
Yeah.
So
I always tell people,
yeah,
cause I get the same exact thing.
Hey,
I'm in this job,
it's miserable.
I don't like it.
Uh,
want to leave tomorrow,
but I don't have the courage.
And I've said,
actually,
it's going to take you more courage to stay in your current job,
formulate an exit strategy,
save up money,
start putting together a better resume,
get some technical skills that you might not have right now.
Do all that while you're suffering in this job that you don't like.
So that when you make the transition,
which will come,
it'll be the right way.
And you won't end up,
like you said,
jumping off of a cliff.
Yeah.
Well,
it also makes you hopeful,
even in the terrible,
because you know,
then you've got some hope and hope is a big deal.
You can,
you can put up with a lot of misery if you've got hope.
But if you think I'm miserable today and I'm going to be miserable Mauro,
and next year I'm going to be older and just as miserable.
It's like,
that's,
that's not good.
But if you think,
well,
I've got a plan,
you know,
that's,
that's a whole different story and it's a good idea of for those veterans that
are out there,
don't just get out,
formulate a plan,
figure out where you're going to go and have that in place.
And then you get out,
you step into,
yeah,
well I'd really like to see the military use this future authoring program for
people who are decommissioning because you need,
you know,
your idea that you need the next mission is that,
that's exactly right.
You know,
life is like a series of missions forward,
you know,
and nested in something greater than that I think.
But you do,
you need to have a plan and you know it,
you've got to kind of hold the plan loosely,
you know,
so because you're gonna make mistakes formulating it.
But the way it works basically is the aim at something in the future.
And so then you start moving forward and as you move forward,
you accrue more experience and more information.
Sometimes that's through failure,
doesn't matter,
but you're not staying in the same place.
So you're actually growing.
Even if you're,
even if you're doing badly,
if you learn from those mistakes,
and so then you move towards the goal and your perspective shifts and then you
might have to modify the goal a bit because now you're a little smarter.
You think,
well,
that other goal wasn't helpful.
It's like,
yes it was because it moved you an inch farther ahead.
And so you know,
you,
you kind of approached the final goal in a zig zag manner and the zigs and zags
get less extreme as you get closer to the final goal.
But you have to do a lot of zigzagging to begin with.
So you've got to give yourself that space for error.
That's why there's an archetypal idea that the fool is the precursor to the
savior,
which is a really,
and you see that with comedians.
Comedians are fools and they tell the truth,
right?
So,
so in the court gestures,
the only person who gets to tell the truth and a fool,
it'll take a risk as well.
And you need to take risks in order to progress.
So that's the idea.
But it also means that you have to allow yourself to make the mistakes that are
necessary while you progress and not beat yourself to death about it.
And so that's also really helpful because it means that when you're formulating
your plans,
you can say,
well,
this is the best I can do now subject to revision.
It's like,
great,
that's good enough.
Really it's good enough.
It just has to move you to the next place.
That's interesting because obviously I've done a ton of military planning and I
would see guys that would get so wrapped around trying to make the perfect plan
and it would take them so long to plan that by the time they're ready to
actually get the plan for the whole target had shifted and things had moved in
the battlefield of change and they're not ready to do this anymore.
So you need to come up with,
like you said,
you need to come up without good idea of what you're going to do and how are you
going to do it.
And then you start to move and,
and,
and as you move,
you start to see things from a different angle and you gain more intelligence
than you get another report and all of a sudden the target shifts a little bit,
but you're adapting and you're closer to the target anyways.
Very,
very interesting.
It's also the idea that you're gaining information,
cause you might say,
well I don't know what to do with my life,
so maybe I should just stay here and figure it out.
It's like,
no,
no.
If you stay there,
then all you know is what you know.
Well you're there and you don't know enough because you can't make a plan.
So make a bad plan.
Even if the,
even if it's actually a plan that works out so that it's opposite of what you
want.
If you move towards that plan,
you're going to know more clearly that it's opposite of what you want.
And as soon as you know that it's opposite,
you know,
or I should be going in the other direction.
So like that's,
that's not,
that's not a retreat.
That's,
that's an advance and thing is people were active creatures and we're always
navigating through territory.
Right.
We can't be sitting in one place and waiting,
well you can't cause you get old.
So you,
even if you're sitting in one place,
the place is changing on you.
And that's just what you said that when you said,
you know,
people make a detailed plan and then the environmental shift on them and on
future authoring.
Yeah.
Do you go back in and adjust your goals?
So it's something that you continually update.
Yeah.
And I would say don't update it too often.
Right?
Because then you end up in the situation you were just describing.
But the idea would probably,
it's something like make your damn plan implemented for four months or six
months and then go back and see what needs to be updated,
you know?
And you'll find that you'll,
you've done a lot of what you said you would and so then it'll need to be
reformulated.
So,
and that's also very self affirming I suppose is the right,
it helps you understand that there's more to you than you think,
which is actually the case.
You know,
there is more to people than they think that that's one thing that's interesting
about human beings.
And so you can put yourself,
you can,
you can stand up to things you're afraid of.
Um,
you know,
in measured doses and you find that you grow to be larger than the thing that
you're afraid of.
And you know,
that's like,
that's like one of the basic rules of clinical therapies.
Like if people are afraid of something,
you break it down into pieces and you have them encounter the things they're
afraid of and they don't get less afraid.
They get braver and more competent,
which is way better cause there's plenty of things to be afraid of.
Once again,
here's just a total alignment.
I wrote this kid's book,
it's called wave.
Okay.
I read it.
I didn't know about this,
but I knew what I did with my kids.
And in the book,
you know,
the kids scared of water and he has not a swim.
So he starts off waiting in the water and then he eventually he dunks his head
in the water and then eventually he covers up to his neck in the water and then
eventually he swims a little bit and then he finally jumps off the page.
But that's when I heard you describing that process and in some interview that
you are on or,
or one of your podcasts,
I said,
ah,
I put that in my,
but I didn't even know it.
It's progressive exposure.
And so what you want to do and what you want to do is you can do this for
yourself.
You think,
okay,
here's something I'm afraid of doing.
Okay.
And so I won't do it cause I'm actually afraid of,
it's okay,
fine.
Decompose it.
Like let's say you're afraid to go on a subway,
you have agoraphobic.
It's like,
okay,
are go online and look at a bunch of pictures of a subway.
Can you do that?
Um,
go to the subway station and look at the subway station and then go home or go
into the subway station and opened the doors and go in and then go home.
But don't,
don't play tricks on yourself,
right?
If you say that you're going to go and just look,
then just go and look and then go home,
you know,
because otherwise you won't trust yourself the next time you do it.
So you have to keep the bargain in tact.
But,
and what you want to do is you want to push yourself a little farther than you
want to go,
but so that you would go,
that's all you have to do.
And that's,
that's kind of a rule for,
for learning in life.
So this happens.
The reason it works is because this is actually how human beings learn.
And so if you watch a kid,
maybe let's say a kid that's a little inhibited because some kids will just take
off,
but we'll use the kids that's literally inhibited.
So they're around their mom and they're in the playground and there's strange
kids there.
Maybe they're like four years old,
something like that.
And so they're thinking about maybe that,
that they'll go out and play.
And so they hang around mum for a while and they check out the situation and
then they'll go out a little bit and check it out a bit more.
And then they come back and maybe they need a little pact or something like
that,
you know,
cause they're coming back to home territory.
Then the next time they go out a little farther,
then they'll come back and the next time they go a little farther and then
they'll come back because they want to know they can come back and they're
checking to see how far out they can go.
And if you're patient and encouraging,
even with kids that are quite nervous,
you know,
you encourage them to,
to,
to keep going out and exploring,
then they'll habituate and well what they do is learn.
They're competent and the way they go.
And so it's not surprising that graduated exposure works because that is
actually how human beings learn to confront the world.
But it's a great technique.
And,
and the story in the book,
it wasn't by my daughter was had stage fright,
but you want it to be in the school musical.
And so it was started with her and her room singing by herself.
But I was outside the door with the door shut.
Yeah.
And then it was okay,
you sing what?
The door is open.
And this happened over,
you know,
a couple of weeks.
Now the door's open.
Now I'm going to stand in the doorway.
Now mom and I are going to stand in the doorway.
Now we're actually gonna come in and sit down and watch you saying.
And then it was the family's going to watch you sing and then the neighbors are
going to come watch you.
I'm,
and eventually she has no,
no issues whatsoever right now.
Very confident kid.
But that was,
yeah,
that's perfect.
I translated it into the water for the story for whatever reason.
But yeah.
Yeah.
Well that also means that,
see what I like about that story too is that you established an individual
relationship with your daughter.
You know,
because kids have different temperaments.
So like some kids,
if you take them to the playground,
it's like they're like pop.
You put them down on the ground,
they're like puppies over water.
Their fetal be going before they hit the ground and they're just gone,
right?
They're out there playing with the kids.
Those are extroverted kids who don't have very high levels of negative emotion
and your problem is going to be that they'll run off too far,
you know,
so,
but then other kids are more,
they're more inhibited and often they're a little more introverted.
They're little higher negative emotion.
So then what you want to do is calibrate and you have to watch.
It's like,
okay,
how much can this kid tolerate?
It's like,
we'll push it and you can,
you can figure that out.
It's like it.
It has to be,
you have to push them enough so that if they accomplish it,
they feel that that's an accomplishment.
It can't be too easy,
but it can't be too hard.
You want to put them right on that edge.
That's the edge between order and chaos,
right?
Fundamentally you want to put them on that edge and let them experience what
it's like to be there.
Then they also learned that they can be there.
Cause you know,
you taught her to things,
you taught her that she could sing in front of a group,
but you also taught her that she could learn to do something she was afraid of
doing.
And that's a way better lesson.
Right?
That's a killer lesson.
So,
so that's good that that means,
and you can do that with kids too with graduated reward,
like,
um,
you can watch them and if they do something,
well,
I'll tell you how I did this with my daughter.
So my daughter had arthritis and it was really bad and she had to learn to give
herself an while.
She had to take injections every day.
And so I think that started when she was like seven.
And so,
um,
we could give her the injections,
but she was pretty skittish about that and no wonder because they hurt and
everything.
So I thought,
all right to hell with this,
we'll,
we'll get her to do her own injections.
And,
uh,
so I sat her down and I said she was pretty motivated by money.
She's always been kind of a capitalist kid day.
So we found her outside once when she was four selling all her child books on
the street,
which was quite funny.
I think she was maybe five,
but whatever.
I said,
look Kiddo,
um,
I'm going to give you this needle and if you can give you,
if you can inject this yourself in 45 minutes,
I'll give you 50 bucks.
And so I let her sit and she likes struggled with that.
She struggled with that a and but by about 30 minutes she did it and I thought
that could work math,
good work.
So then the next time I said,
okay,
this time it's 30 bucks,
but you got 10 minutes to do it.
And so she did it and you know,
soon we got it down so that it,
cause I wanted to get it down so there was no hesitation,
right,
because actually the anticipatory anxiety is worse than the needle,
so you want to push it.
So it's like,
okay now,
and we got to the point where it was,
um,
if you can do it in five seconds we'll give you 10 bucks.
And so she got to the point,
took about a week where she could do it in five seconds and I kept paying or
because,
well for obvious reasons,
you know,
I mean it was kind of unfortunate.
She was very sick and she had these needles and we had to do some things that
would sort of perk her up,
you know,
to some degree.
But that was a hard
thing for a kid to learn.
You know,
it's not an easy thing to give yourself a needle,
but you can use that graduated exposure and careful reward.
You can get kids to do very brief things and then they also learn how tough they
are.
It's like hike.
And she was proud of that man.
You know,
she that she could go and do it by herself cause that was a big deal.
It also gave her some control over your illness.
So competence,
that's what you want to instill in your kids.
Less.
You're jealous of them.
So now you also talked about,
you started talking about some various personality traits and how those come
through and you just released what a month ago,
a new program,
understand yourself,
understand myself doors,
call myself.com.
Yeah.
And I also put up a discount code for your people for that too.
So it's willing again,
and it's 20%.
It's,
that would make it about seven 95.
So it's pretty cheap.
Um,
what you do is it,
you answer a hundred questions,
the questions are pretty standard,
like they've been derived from the standard scientific literature.
Um,
partly from a test that I designed that my students designed about,
uh,
in 2007 Colon de Young,
who's now a professor at the University of Minnesota and Wi wi Wi wi
statistically analyze this question set so we could break out five major
personality traits.
And those are the standard traits that psychologists believe are reliable and
valid.
And they'd been working on that since about 1960.
And so that's extroversion.
And that's,
uh,
um,
it can,
it breaks into two aspects.
So extroverted people are assertive and enthusiastic.
It's the positive emotion dimension.
They're talkative a and they like to be in social groups.
They like to plan parties,
they like,
they like to talk,
um,
and they're smiley and so forth.
Um,
and then there's a negative emotion,
dimension.
Neuroticism and people who are high in neuroticism are that can be broken into
withdrawal and volatility and people who withdraw.
I have a lot of anticipatory anxiety so they might shy away from doing something
and volatile people are kind of touchy,
you know,
they're easily set off.
So,
um,
agreeableness,
agreeable people are compassionate and polite.
Disagreeable people are tough and blunt and so women are higher in agreeableness
than men and they're higher in negative emotion as well.
Conscientiousness,
which is the best long term predictor of life.
Success after intelligence.
Conscientious people are dutiful and uh,
so they're industrious and orderly.
And orderliness is a good predictor of conservative political philosophy by the
way or political affiliation along with low.
The last dimension is openness and open.
People are interested in ideas,
so that's intellect and creative.
And we call that openness.
Its openness to experiences.
The main trade and the creativity trade is o is openness proper.
So this report gives you a comparative description so you compared to other
people on all five of those dimensions plus all of those
10 aspects and that can help you understand who you are.
And that's very useful because one of the things you want to do in life is
figure out what your temperament is so that you can find a niche in the economy
or in the social world that you're suited to.
So like if you're an introvert,
while computer programming stone,
a bad idea or accounting or something like that.
But if you're extroverted,
you got to be out with people you know.
And if you're high in negative emotion,
you're going to want a job that's not too stressful and it's fairly secure.
And if you're open,
then you're an entrepreneurial or creative type.
And if you're agreeable,
you should be working with people and if you're disagreeable,
you should be working with things.
And so the,
anyways,
the reports detail,
all of that.
And so then once people see where they fall out,
they can kind of put themselves into a better position,
like you said it
job that suits them.
And that's going to be,
yeah,
well,
yeah.
Well that's,
well that's it.
You know,
it's,
you,
you do have a temperament and there is a place for each temperament in the
economy,
in the world because otherwise they wouldn't exist.
And so the issue is what is your temperament?
So if you're high in openness,
you need,
you need to engage in something creative because you won't be healthy if you
don't cause it's like a major,
probably if you're like a tree with different trunks,
it's like that's one of the trucks.
It might be the major one.
You can't let that thing die because it'll take a big part of it with you.
And if you're disagreeable,
say you're a competitive type and so you're going to need some of that in your
life.
And if your conscientiousness,
if you're conscientious,
that's a pretty good predictor of military,
uh,
um,
performance by the way,
then you need a routine and you need to be,
you need to be locked on to some task,
you know,
cause otherwise you'll,
you'll consume yourself with guilt.
Um,
so,
so it's very important to understand who you are in that way.
And it's also,
that's interesting because that's,
I can tell you that that's sort of the middle of the bell curve and even like
towards the higher end of the bell curve of military performers are,
you know,
people that are can concentrate on the task.
They're going to be relatively obedient.
But when you get to either end,
either high end,
either the low end of bad performance,
but also the high end or the people that no one to break the rules that are
slightly rebellious,
that will rebel look,
that will tell,
you know,
one of the big ones,
I don't want to be surrounded by people that are telling me that I'm right all
the time.
I don't want my subordinates.
I don't want to have people that are working for me that are going to,
when I say go charge at machine gun nest,
so they say,
okay,
and they go do it.
You might think that that's what I want and that might be the,
the overall perception of people in the military.
I want a robot that's going to follow my orders.
I actually don't,
if I tell you to go charge that machine gun nest and it's not and it's going to
get you and your men killed,
I actually want you to say,
Hey Jocko,
that doesn't sound like a good plan to me.
Let's do something else.
Let's come around to the flank.
So,
so it's interesting that yeah,
you'll be good in that middle part and you might even get towards higher end.
But the guys
that are really valuable in the military are the guys that also have that
openness and that creativity and are and at the same time are able to discipline
it and harness it so that they can conform when they need to.
They need to be,
which I actually had to do as I got older,
the older,
when I first got in,
you know,
I was the guy pushing the envelope,
I long hair and so everything that I could do with maxed out to,
to stay within the bounds of what we are supposed to be doing.
And,
and then as I got older I realized like,
oh,
that stuff's not important.
What's important is that you're able to do your job good and you have
creativity,
not with how you have your stupid haircut,
but in how you come up with a mission plan.
Right?
That's where I express my creativity,
not through,
not through pushing the envelope of uniform standards,
which is,
which is what a lot of immature young military guys do.
Right?
Well,
the thing about,
uh,
um,
the people who will stand up and tell you what they think is that they tend to
be disagreeable types as well.
And you know,
you hear a lot about emotional intelligence in the business world these days,
but emotional intelligence is really indistinguishable from trait agreeableness.
And so agreeable people are polite and compassionate and that's great,
especially if you're taking care of people,
but you want some disagreeable people around because they'll tell you what they
think and they're blunt.
Well this isn't an emotional intelligence though.
Can't you be agreeable but not be able to re.
I always think of it as me being able to read people like I understand,
oh that person's got events going on.
That's their agenda is in the background.
So even though I might be agreeable,
but I'm also understanding where you're coming from.
That's what emotional intelligence is,
if it's anything valid.
But the tests that test at tend to correlate very highly with agreeableness.
And so actually agreeable managers don't make better bit managers.
Disagreeable managers make better managers.
Well they have to be conscientious as well cause a disagreeable person who's
conscientious is actually relatively easy to work for it because they'll tell
you what they think,
but they'll do what they say,
you know,
and they can make tough decisions.
And you often have to make decisions that are somewhat harsh in order to move
things ahead in the long term.
Right.
Because if you're soft,
it means you'll sacrifice the sh the long term for the short term.
And if you're tough,
but,
but have your head screwed on straight,
it means you'll make tough decisions in the present that might ruffle feathers
and hurt people's feelings,
but they make the medium to longterm better.
And so that's absolutely true.
I see that all the time,
especially with younger companies.
They go through that expansion phase and all of a sudden they got up,
they go through the attraction phase and they got to fire people and,
and they wait because the leader is too agreeable and too soft and so they wait
and all of a sudden they're upside down financially and it's a real problem.
Whereas if they would have been aggressive and said,
you know what,
here's the decision we've got to make.
I know it's going to hurt right now,
but long term it can be good for us.
We've got to get rid of this division or this department are these people.
And if they don't have the ability to do that,
it really hurts them in the long.
Yeah.
Well,
that's the sacrifice of the future for the present.
And that's generally a bad.
The other thing
with the understand myself,
uh,
system is that you can also use it to like if you do the program and get your
results in someone else,
does someone you're close to say you can compare them.
And that's really useful because you think you understand people but you don't
understand them as well as you think.
So for example,
my daughter was fairly,
well,
she,
she was quite ill,
so it was complicated,
but she was,
um,
touchy,
let's say when she was a teenager and I thought it was because she was
rebellious,
but she did the personality test and my son by contrast was very easy to get
along with.
But then we had them do the personality test and it turned out she was very high
in agreeableness and compassion,
but also pretty high in negative emotion.
Whereas he was the opposite.
He was very disagreeable but very low and negative emotions.
So he wasn't easy to get along with.
He just never got upset.
But if you ever tried to get them to do something he didn't want to do,
that was like impossible.
And he was like that from the time he was two years old.
Whereas my daughter,
it wasn't rebellious ness,
it was that she was easily made anxious and upset.
And so I learned at least somewhat.
So if she,
if she sort of flared up instead of interpreting that as,
as rebelliousness or,
or,
or conflict,
I just saw it as nervousness and that helped a lot.
You know,
it didn't make me able to deal with it 100%,
but it helped a lot.
It was quite shocking to me because,
you know,
I thought I knew my kids and uh,
and I did I think,
but that was very useful.
And then it was really funny because then as she started to date,
she had every boyfriend she ever went out with take the personality test first.
So I thought that was really comical.
Not Actually worked out quite well.
Well,
the thing is,
you know,
you,
you want to be boys,
not smart enough to like manipulate the answers so they don't necessarily know
what she wants.
So,
you know,
I would at least assume like,
okay,
I'm going to try and sound agreeable and I'm going to try it.
I remember I had to take a psychological tests too,
and this was in the 90s they give us ones.
You'd think they had some big battery of psychological examinations in
interviews to get in the seal teams?
No,
it took like a one task during bootcamp.
And it was funny because I was really hungry when I was in bootcamp because the
food sucks and,
and I just thought,
man,
I want to pass this test.
And I knew I had some things in my brain that weren't going to be smiled upon by
whatever analyst was going to read these things.
So,
and was complete the sent.
These are the things I remember it was complete the sentence.
So it said,
for instance,
I hate when my mom and you fill in the blank and obviously it's real easy to go
sideways on that.
Then right.
I mean if you're a psychopath,
but for me,
every answer that I gave was,
you know,
for me it was,
I hate when my mom doesn't cook enough noodles with the Spaghetti.
Every single day I gave were just about food.
They must have thought I was a food psychopath.
They were getting nothing out of me,
nothing.
Um,
I think the tested my daughter used was one I designed that people couldn't
fake.
So it wasn't quite as accurate with regards to the individual personality
traits,
but it was,
it was more difficult to fake good on,
which is better for hiring people.
For example.
What kind of question can you not fake in?
Oh,
well,
are you hardworking or are you easy to get along with?
Right.
Are you creative?
Are disciplined.
Oh,
right,
right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Are you neurotic and anxious or are you a inhibited and and awkward with people?
Can you go in between,
is it a one to 10 it's either or.
Yeah.
Without,
with that particular pairing.
It is.
And then you've paired all these questions so that eventually you get,
that's right.
That's right.
Well or,
or maybe here's 10 negative statements which five applied to you.
Most people hate those particularly,
but they're quite accurate.
So we use those for personnel selection for awhile.
So for me it would be are you agreeable of disciplined,
hungry?
Yeah.
Now before we close that you are,
you also have,
um,
the book maps of meaning and,
and for those people that were expecting me to do the book maps of meaning on
this podcast and review it in depth,
there is literally no reason because you have already done that online on
Youtube and on your podcast you go through in great detail,
better detail than I would have been able to in one podcast because you have a
series of podcasts about maps of meeting.
It's fascinating.
It's awesome.
Everything that you kind of touched on today is in there in great depth.
Um,
and you know there's many worshipers of Marduk out there now,
thanks to you and,
and I'm sure that will expand.
And if you want to get into that,
the book is called maps of meaning the architecture of belief.
It's very interesting.
I also like that you have the,
the,
you talk about some of your clients as which,
by the way,
I didn't talk about you at all in the opening.
I realized that about halfway through this podcast that I didn't actually
explain who you were.
So is there anything you'd need to say about yourself that I should have said?
I mean,
what,
well,
there's just the bare basics.
Cologists I've practiced for about two and a half decades.
I've done a lot of business consulting,
um,
uh,
as well as clinical work.
I'm a professor at the University of Toronto in psychology and I might domains
of expertise,
our personality assessment and neuroscience and the study of belief systems,
like religious belief systems.
And,
and I,
that's basically the,
I,
I have a family.
I'm married and have been for just about 30 years and I've got two kids and a
new grandchild.
And so that's,
and I've become somewhat notorious on youtube over the last year.
Really.
It's been that.
And so that's been quite bizarre.
A trip you might say,
so.
So everyone can go and explore that.
Yeah,
you're pretty.
Um,
I guess the other thing I should say,
because my publicist
will be on my case if I don't as that I have another book coming out,
which is much more straight forward than maps of meeting,
which is quite a technical book
and that button's is going to be called 12 rules for life.
Yeah.
An antidote to chaos.
And it's available for preorder on Amazon already.
So January 23rd that's when it comes out.
Yep.
And I'm hoping that now that one,
maybe you come back on here and we could talk a little bit about that book.
That'd be good.
That would be,
that would be good.
Um,
that book will be right up.
I mean,
you've touched on it a little bit.
You've mentioned a couple of the 12 rules today.
I think you mentioned two of the 12 rules today and that would be awesome to
have you come back on.
And again,
I think people after they hear this,
if they didn't already know who you are,
they'll,
they'll go and research or you are,
and they're going to want to get that book.
And it'd be great to have you back on there.
And then obviously you've got your own podcast.
Yup.
The Jordan B.
Peterson podcasts.
Yes.
You've got
your youtube channel.
Yep.
Jordan [inaudible],
Jordan Peterson videos
and Jordan Peterson clips.
You just put out echo wasn't that crafty to come out with a thing,
like a separate thing to channels.
Yeah.
So he's got two James,
he's the one that's supposed to make the clips.
Yeah.
Well one of the things that's been so strange,
I mean learning to use Youtube,
um,
people have been clipping my work like mad,
which is not something I expected.
Like I would say right now there's probably 40 new clips a day being put on by
people,
which is really good,
you know,
I mean,
I've got no problem with that at all,
but I thought I might as well see what would happen if we also did it.
And so I put my,
my,
my uh,
son's fiance on that and my daughter as well.
So they've been doing that clipping.
And so,
but yeah,
it's cool that youtube videos are so interesting as well as the podcasts because
people can can do their own thing with them to some degree,
you know,
not can be bad depending on how they do the editing.
But so far people have been responding very positively to what I've been doing,
which is quite a shock to me.
Um,
but I think it,
I think it,
and you've made reference to this as well,
in,
in the,
in the fact that you've found a ready audience is like people are ready for a
message that's not all freedom and,
and writes,
you know,
it's like Jesus,
enough of that,
like really seriously,
we'd been walking down that road for 60 years.
It's time to look at the alternative ethics and responsibility.
That's a big one.
Especially when it is the case that you know,
you think freedom gives you life more meaning that's true if you're under a
tyranny.
But if you're not,
then it's responsibility that gives your life meaning and you,
you,
your life has to have meaning.
It has negative meaning,
whether you want it or not,
you choose whether or not it has positive meaning.
And you'd choose that by adopting responsibility.
And so and like there's a ready market that,
because
we've,
we've ignored that reality for too long.
So [inaudible]
are now at the point where they realize that being free,
free,
free isn't getting them anywhere.
Yeah.
Well,
I always think it's like,
you know,
you okay,
you want to be free,
all right,
I'll take you and drop you in the middle of the ocean.
It's like you can swim in any direction.
It's like,
that's not helpful.
You know,
you,
you gotta be swimming,
be different.
If I dropped you near an island and said,
well,
swim to that.
It's like,
yeah,
I can do that.
That's,
that's got meaning.
I won't drown.
I won't die.
But too much.
There's no difference between too much freedom and chaos.
Right.
And you drown in chaos.
You need the right balance of freedom and order and,
and,
and discipline.
Well,
as you said also,
which is a paradoxical thing,
the more discipline you have,
the more self disciplined,
the more freedom.
Even even putting in those hour breaks that you described.
You know,
sometimes when I've been too busy,
which has been fairly frequent,
um,
I'll take an hour break,
you know,
and I can actually have a break because I've done the things that I was supposed
to do.
And so even though it's an hour long,
I can actually relax during that hour not being plagued by my conscience or
aren't things undone,
you know?
And so that's,
that's,
that's a really good thing to be able to attain when you feel that you've got
things,
you've got the right things reasonably under control and you're moving uphill,
that's better than anything else really.
Yeah.
Um,
speaking of getting things under control echo,
yeah.
Maybe could you tell people quickly how they could support this podcast?
I'll try to make it,
I kind of feel like we should keep talking about little,
we've been talking,
I hear you actually have a question.
Two questions.
Okay.
So with the recent,
everyone waits for in the podcast questions a little bit more,
you know,
with the rise of your,
uh,
exposure,
we'll call it.
Do people kind of flock to your class now?
Well,
no,
not so much to my class,
but they're definitely flocking to public talks.
Uh,
yeah.
So and,
and,
and my,
my class is generally being quite popular,
you know,
so that's so and makes sense.
Yeah.
And I'm on Sabbatical this year,
so we'll see what happens when I,
when I returned.
Was that luck or did you pre coordinate that?
Well,
it was actually the grace,
good grace of the university,
you know,
because,
well,
I had to get my act back together after all these things happened,
you know,
and I've also had some health problems over the last year that had been rather
severe,
which I think I have under control maybe.
Um,
but I,
I told them that,
look,
I,
I'm going to be much better if I take this year and do what's necessary for this
book that's coming out and re conceptualize what I'm going to be teaching.
Because the other thing is I have to do that.
I've got all these lectures recorded now they're on youtube.
It's like it isn't obvious to me why I should do them again.
I've done like,
there's three years of some of them online,
so I have to re,
I have to rethink what I'm doing as a university lecturer because with youtube,
you know you can do something new,
like this Biblical series that I've been doing,
you can do something new and you can have it out in front of 150,000 people in
one day.
It's like,
well you got to think about that.
That's a whole different universe.
And I like doing lectures on things that I'm,
I'm still learning about.
It's hard to do that at a university because you have to have the evaluation
structure.
People have to know what to expect and you know,
it has to be preplanned and that's not so good if you want to do something
that's novel.
So I've got a lot of thinking about that and I don't know what's going to happen
this next year in any case.
So do you find that like,
um,
like let's say you did a talk about something specific and people thought
online.
I think a lot of times people are more compelled to see that same one in person,
like a concert,
you know,
like,
Oh yeah,
I listened to,
I dunno,
Zz Top,
I'll listen to this easy.
And you know,
I have the CD or whatever,
but they're in town for a concert or their,
you know,
in the next day for a concert,
I want to go see the concert.
Well,
I think I,
I think that that works out okay for me because there are these underlying
themes that,
that permeate everything that I'm saying.
And I would say those are the archetypal themes.
So I have this sort of structured way of presenting information that's based on,
well,
the work I did for maps of meaning.
And so even if the lecture's knew,
there's echoes of the,
of the other ones always,
I mean one of the things about archetipal stories is that an images is that
they're very expensive,
you know,
and so they're multifaceted and so you end up touching on the same themes over
and over,
but from different perspectives,
you know,
and one of the things people tell me all the time,
which is really interesting and this is really been the case for 30 years as
they come up to me after the lecture and they say,
you know,
you were telling me things that I already knew but I didn't know.
I knew that.
And that's,
that's definitely an archetypal experience because you know,
your,
your experience does have a certain structure and that doesn't mean you can say
what it is,
but if you hear it being said,
then you know that that's what it is.
And so it's fun in front of a crowd because I can watch that happen to people
they,
cause I'm always speaking to individuals within the crowd and I'll say something
and someone will go like this.
Yeah,
your eyes are open,
a little bit of the jerk back a little bit.
And I think yes.
So that just clicked a couple of things to the other for you,
which is really,
well,
it's fun.
I get the same thing with uh,
with extreme ownership.
The book and you know,
it's about leadership principles and we say in the book,
these are not new.
These are been around for hundreds and in some cases,
thousands of years of how militaries run organizations.
And therefore the military leadership principles are actually the same as all
leadership principles.
Cause you're trying to get a bunch of crazy human beings to do something that's
going to behind a mission and execute it in the most efficient way.
But people say,
Oh,
you know,
I kind of,
I always,
I always thought that I should do that.
I've always done that.
Yeah.
But it,
but yeah,
you captured it and it,
and it's a self awareness.
I think when people,
they,
maybe they do have good natural leadership judgment and they've always taken
responsibility for things,
but they never really thought about it.
They just kind of did it well.
Then once they know,
hey,
I need to take ownership of things,
well then then they really can do it.
And they also see it in their subordinate leadership and they call,
that guy is not taking ownership of things.
They're not doing a good job.
And it's the same thing with keeping things simple or decentralized command or
prioritize next,
because these are things that successful leaders do prioritize and execute.
If you get a leader that's going to try and accomplish 37 different things at
the same time,
they're not going to be successful.
So,
so leaders they know to prioritize and execute good leaders.
But when we say it to them,
you know,
they might still,
they might not do 37 things,
but they might do,
try and do eight things at the same time and they know that they should be doing
one or two.
And,
and when,
when they hear us say it and describe it,
they call it.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's one of the things that characterized as a leader is that he or she knows
where they're going.
Right.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's the fundamental print middle to communicate it to.
But that's,
I worked for a UN committee at one point,
Tom,
oh no.
Uh,
economic sustainability,
economic and environmental sustainability.
And one of the problems with the first draft of the report,
and I would say the final draft to some degree is that,
you know,
it was all done by committees.
So there are a hundred priorities.
It's like,
no,
there aren't a hundred priorities.
That's a contradiction in terms.
It's like you start with one of these things and maybe you start with a small
piece of it and see if it works,
but it's two to have a hundred priorities is to make no one dissatisfied,
but you're not going to,
you're not going to move because you can't move in a hundred directions at the
same time.
So it's a real abdication of,
and,
and people do that in a sneaky way to,
because they're abdicating their responsibility,
right?
Say,
well,
we're going to move in a hundred directions and,
and everyone had input.
It's like,
well that's not the issue.
The issue is how you condense that down to an actual action plan and that
actually makes you accountable.
That's the thing.
And that's why people don't do it.
It's like,
well,
if you're going in a hundred directions and it's hard to see whether you're,
you're doing it well,
but if you're going to one direction that doesn't work,
it's like,
well that's pretty obvious.
So people are afraid to do that,
but if you don't do it,
it's failure.
Yeah.
I get the same thing where I get people now,
they asked me a question and I give them the answer next.
I know you're going to say that.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm one of those people,
by the way,
he does that from time to time.
Also,
how you were talking about kind of breaking the loop in your behavior,
like,
oh,
I want to make a change to that one thing,
you know,
to break the loo and then you start with something small and then it ends up
affecting more thing.
And you mentioned sometimes it's hard because you don't get pats on the back for
those little things,
you know?
Yeah.
Well and so small that then it's humiliating that you even have to do that.
But in a lot of time,
like to yourself,
it's like kind of big.
Like I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to drink eight glasses of water a day now.
You know?
And then it's almost like you're seeking that pat on the back.
Like you want to tell your friend like,
hey,
I drink eight glasses of water now.
And they're just like,
yeah,
so yeah.
Right.
And you're like,
why do I even party use kind of like,
why do I even do it then if no one's going to care,
you know?
Well,
you know,
there,
there's a lesson to be drawn from that too in terms of relationships that's
really useful psychologically is,
and this is a big mistake that people won't make.
It's like if you want to have a good long term relationship with someone,
then you watch them constantly and when they do something that you like,
you let them know,
even if it's a small thing because they're way more likely to do it again,
you know?
And so sometimes a personal have kind of an inkling about what they might do
that's good or that would be good for your real,
their relationship with you.
Or that might even just be pleasing to you,
but they won't say anything.
They're like afraid because maybe they won't get attention for it and,
but then they do it and you notice it's like,
man,
that's super powerful.
Like you have to be really attentive though.
Cause the good things that people do don't stand out and mistakes.
They make stand out and then you say,
well you made a mistake.
It's like,
yeah,
but to,
to watch and to reward someone for doing something small.
Right.
That's,
that's a step in the right direction.
He's a killer strategy.
I found that to be true with my daughter.
She's four and a half.
No.
Oh yeah,
like that.
Some kids really like some kids are tough and they don't respond to punishment
at all.
So you can get,
you just can't,
you can't,
you can't intimidate them.
My daughter,
if I just pointed at her,
she would stop.
But my son,
it was like,
that was just round one.
He just laughed.
He just laughed and ran away,
you know,
so,
but he responded to reward like mad if I watched him and he did something that
was good and I told him that it was like he was just yes.
So Dang,
that's good.
Yeah.
It's reward is harder to use,
but it's more effective if you can manage it.
And then that's not like Kinda how you say we're,
you're like,
be careful with the reward when you give like too much for you word for these
small things,
you know?
And then the [inaudible] going to think that that's a problem with the self
esteem movement.
You know,
every,
every kid gets a trophy day.
It's no,
it's like inflating the currency.
If everything is good,
then nothing is good because their house,
there has to be a distinction.
So yeah,
you want to watch and you want to see when the person's made an effort and you
want to see when they've gone beyond the call of duty,
then you want to say,
Hey,
I noticed that.
That was really good.
Yeah.
And,
and it is scarcity really matters in those situations because otherwise it just
turns into noise.
Yeah.
Patronizing noise even,
which is even worse.
It's like all you're doing well or doing well,
what's it like?
Leave me alone.
Eh,
you know,
it's such a lie.
I have a fun time with that actually.
I'll put like,
um,
if I have to judge and all through my kids' lives,
if I had to judge them and their friends and I have three daughters and one son,
usually it was the daughters.
I was being some kind of a judge.
I'm going to judge the dance,
I'm going to judge the little play that they put together.
I'm going to judge the,
uh,
acrobatic routine that they're doing in the backyard.
And I always be judging these things and I would have so much fun because I
would say they'd do their little performance there,
one minute performance,
and they'd come out table,
how was it?
And I say,
okay,
first of all,
presentation overall,
I'm giving you a 4.2.
I didn't see one smile until you actually got on stage.
That's raw.
And I would just go through and give them these really strong critique points.
Yeah.
And,
and they loved it.
They loved it.
That's mad.
They would be happy to,
and they'd go try it again and try to race that 4.3 to a 4.5 they'd be smiles
like you could see from a mile away.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just got done,
it was at a,
at a pool party with a bunch of little kids running around and I ended up
judging the diving competition and all the parents were watching and they were
aghast at what I was doing.
Yeah.
That was in my house by the way.
Oh,
I did it there too.
You know,
I do it all the way,
but I did it at your house too,
right?
Yeah.
You've seen it in action.
I give the kids a little nicknames and then,
and then I say,
you know,
you were completely unbalanced when you left the board.
It was almost embarrassing for me to watch you go try it again.
I'm giving you a 2.2 yeah.
Go try it again and see if you can bump that up a little bit.
Yeah.
And the kids get all motivated to go up there.
And I give him a two,
2.5 year,
treated
them like someone who could improve.
True.
Right.
So that's a big deal.
That's,
that's better than,
that's better than a pat on the back.
It's like,
because everyone's flawed and everyone needs to improve.
Well,
so when my kids were little,
I taught them how to speak in public.
It took about an hour.
That was it.
So I had them,
they had to read something,
you know,
and so they'd read it and I was across the room and say,
well,
that's not loud enough.
It's like,
I can't hear Ya.
It's like belted out.
And they get a little louder and said,
no,
I,
that is what I mean,
read it way louder than you think you should.
And so they did that.
And I said,
well,
that's about right,
because there's nothing more appalling than listening to some speaker that you
can't hear.
It's like there's just no excuse for that.
And then like,
make it clearer,
put some passion into it,
you know?
And it was,
it was unbelievable how quickly they would pick that up,
you know?
And,
and uh,
that also made me sad because,
because it took so little time to get them to do that and then they had it,
you know?
And so,
and that,
that like a critic is your best friend if the critic isn't destructive cause it,
what a critic does is say,
look,
you did 10 things and like these five things,
you need some work on those.
They're not good.
And here's some things you could do that would make them better.
And here's two things that you got.
All right,
and here's three things that you did pretty well at.
And so then,
well,
what's the message?
The message is,
hey,
you can handle some actual criticism so you're not some little,
you know,
useless,
wimpy thing that's going to die.
Just because someone isn't telling you that you're already wonderful,
plus you're not already what,
not nearly as wonderful as you could get.
So let's keep that in mind.
And then you know,
you lay out a pathway for improvement and then you treat the kid with some
respect.
And,
and you also show that being an adult means that you know more than being a kid
cause you,
you know,
the kid does something,
you say,
oh that was really good.
It's like,
what are you saying?
Well as an adult,
I don't know any better than you do.
And that's pretty dismal message because the kid is going to be an adult for a
very long time.
And one of the things we do really badly in our culture is model.
Why being an adult is better than being a child because it is better.
You have freedom and you have responsibility and you have autonomy.
And so we're always so concerned about making our kids feel good about
themselves.
It's like they should feel good about becoming responsible adults because
they're going to be adults for like 80 years and they're going to be kids for
like 20 years.
So
the adults,
the goal.
So,
yeah,
those are interesting when you started doing that because the kids are like
seven years old and under and he's like letting them have it.
But you,
you're funny,
you have this kind of tone about too though,
when you talk to kids that it's like,
it's almost like live that much over theatrical that month.
So you can tell he's like playing a character.
Right.
And the kids love it.
It's so funny.
My daughter like loves him.
Um,
and the kids are just scrambling around wanting to do it again and they let me
do this.
Let me do it.
Your daughter's all youth do it.
She's like,
okay.
Okay.
That's so funny.
So funny kids though,
you know,
big Jocko legal ordering.
These kids love attention.
Yeah.
It's their currency and they want attention because adults actually know more
than they do.
And so if you pay careful attention,
like I get along really well with little kids and it's because I pay attention
to them and if they do something good,
then we had this kid over at our house once.
This is a sad story.
I told it in my new book.
Um,
so this kid was about four really cute kid,
really nice looking kid.
And,
uh,
his nanny had been hurt in a car accident,
so he was kinda being shuffled around the neighborhood for,
for daycare for like a week or so away.
And I'd heard some,
not some rumors about this kid.
And so I was kind of curious.
And so anyways,
he came over to our house.
My,
my,
my wife was also taken care of some other kids at this time.
Um,
and I came home and he was standing,
the other kids were playing in the living room and he was standing in the porch,
sort of in the corner,
you know,
kind of just wandering around back and forth.
And I looked at him and I thought,
that's not so good.
So I kind of poked him a bit,
you know,
and I was poking them and trying to get him to play and he had this like really
mask of a face on unhappy and I poke him and he kind of jerk away and all that
and I couldn't get him to smile and I couldn't get them to play it.
I thought,
that's
not good.
That's not good.
Cause he's four,
like he should have
acted unhappy for two or three pokes and then kind of laughed and then we would
kind of get into it,
you know,
so,
so that,
that wasn't so good.
So then we had lunch and the rule at our house was eat your damn lunch and say
thank you to the person who made it because otherwise they'll cook you horrible
things and you'll die.
So it's like,
it's hard to cook lunch for.
You have some gratitude,
you little monsters.
And so you ate what was there.
And so his mother,
when she dropped him off,
said he probably won't eat anything all day,
but that's all right.
And we thought,
well actually no,
that's not all right because he needs to eat and,
and it's,
and it's not all right that he doesn't eat wrong.
And so we'd learned how to feed recalcitrant children by that point.
And so all the kids were at the table and they were eating and my wife had made
some chicken stew and he wasn't eating.
And so she was trying to feed them.
And so we were watching him very carefully and so she bring up the spoon to his
mouth and he'd like move his head back and forth,
you know,
to refuse it.
And it was just like about a nine month old would do that a,
when you're trying to f that's there their first trick.
And so that's a nine month old trick.
And we thought,
okay,
well something happened when he was nine months old and he never really got
beyond that.
And so,
um,
you know,
my wife was fairly persistent with the spoon and
he'd get annoyed and you know,
a squawk bit.
She'd put some food in and then he'd swallow it.
And then,
and then as soon as he took a little bit of food and she'd pat him and tell him
that he was being a good kid and she,
man today was not a game.
Like she was really intent on getting this kid to have lunch and so,
so that's fine.
And he's moving his,
his head back and forth.
But what was cool as she kept patting him on the head and telling him he was
good kid,
he was opening his mouth more often,
even though he was still moving his head back and forth.
And so it took about 10 minutes or so and she'd fed him the whole bowl of
chicken stew and she said,
she showed him and he said,
look,
you're a good boy.
You ate all of it.
And that horrible mask that he was wearing,
you know,
that mask of unhappiness,
it just fell off of.
And he had this great smile.
It was just,
it just made the hair on the back of my neck stand up because you could see that
was the first damn thing that he had been allowed to succeed at,
you know?
And so he was thrilled.
And then for the rest of the day he followed my wife around like a puppy dog.
Like he was one step behind her.
And then we went downstairs into the basement and we were watching TV and he
climbed up in her lap and he grabbed onto her just like there's this famous
experiment that Harlow did with monkeys and the monkeys could either have the
wire mother that fed them milk or the cuddly mother that they could claim two,
they were both artificial and the monkeys preferred the cuddly mother,
you know?
And that's what it was like.
He was just wrapped around her,
you know,
and then his mother came home and she came downstairs and she took one look at
this kid wrapped around my wife and she said,
oh,
super.
And grabbed him and then walked out.
And I thought,
ew,
that was horrible.
That was a horrible thing to see because he was in one day with that kid,
you'd,
you'd fix him up,
you know,
it was one positive experience was enough to bring them out of his shell and you
know,
it's okay that he doesn't eat.
It's okay that he stands in the corner,
doesn't play with the other kids,
you know,
it's okay that he's miserable and unhappy.
It's like,
Hey,
guess what?
That's not okay.
It's not even a little bit.
Okay.
So that's a good example of the use of reward.
You know,
it,
it just,
it was something to see.
I'll tell you.
Yeah.
Well,
speaking of breaking the loops,
we'll talk about origin.
So origin American made stuff,
uh,
Jocko has his own line of supplements.
So in the event of your joints,
because that's really the main one,
your joints,
Jocko,
Super Krill.
Krill oil better than fish oil,
by the way.
What do you make of this when someone,
Kay,
so krill oil back in the day,
my wife's Dad,
my father in law used to always say,
could take Krill oils for your joint.
It's good.
And he's one of these like health for lack of better term health nuts,
right?
I don't know if that's good or bad,
but,
and he'd be like,
yeah,
Krill oil.
It's even even better than fish oil.
I'm like,
cool.
Never listen,
never listen.
But then when Jocko,
for some reason takes,
doesn't even say to take it,
just like he takes it,
then I start taking it and I reaped the benefits of course.
Cause Krill oil is dope.
But what do you make of that?
What of the Krill oil do for you?
Just it helped.
So you know how you get joint just from working out and doing stuff,
you know,
you can join,
get sore,
especially when you get older,
whatever.
In my experience.
Um,
so I started taking Krill oil and here's the example,
I said it before,
I'll try to make it quick.
So my daughter,
she was four,
she was maybe three at the time,
three Sunday.
Um,
and in the morning how she'd wake me up,
issued,
she'd wake me up and then when I get up she jumped on my back,
kind of like she wouldn't let me walk downstairs without her and her bag on my
back.
So when she do that,
you know,
you just woke up,
you not warm,
but you may or may not have,
you know,
worked out,
did some training,
whatever.
So you kind of got an exercise like perfect form to stand up with this little
girl who's moving on your,
on your back,
otherwise you get get injured.
So after it was about six days of taking Krill oil,
I didn't have to like,
it was like I was already warm.
That was the feeling.
That's what I did.
That's cool.
But why do I listen to Jocko and take Krill oil and not my father in law?
He went,
oh,
he's telling me the same stove.
Often having an example instead of being told is more effective,
you know?
And there's a confidence,
I think that goes along with someone doing something and not telling you about
it.
Yeah.
You've been psychologically unwound.
Well nonetheless.
So on top of that job was his own krill oil.
So you know,
that's the good ones.
Super Krill,
not just regular super,
by the way.
Also joint warfare,
which is a bunch of other ingredient.
Is that Glucosamine Chondroitin?
Yup.
Yeah.
You got the perfect formula for joint sustainable joint maintenance and health
perfection.
That's from origin origin lab.
So origin main.com on the top menu labs.
Boom.
That's where you get it.
Is there like a,
I think there's like a,
anyway,
there's a link on the story anyway.
There needs to be like on our store there is,
yeah,
there has reads,
boom right there.
Whatever he need.
Also Giza and rash guards.
If you introduce the into Jujitsu Jordan Peterson,
I'm not resilient Jujitsu,
there's not much call for that as a professor.
Seemingly seemingly videos where you might've wanted [inaudible] in your back
pocket.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well we've got one coming up on November 11th to talk on free speech and I'm
afraid there's going to be plenty of trouble at it.
I hope not,
and I hope that everybody you need security.
I got crews.
Yeah.
Dang,
that happened.
Boom.
There you go.
Nonetheless,
if you are into Jiu Jitsu,
they get some good gies American made by the way for what are,
you know if you're into the American made stuff from beginning to end.
Yeah.
Actually I was born in Canada by the way,
where Victoria?
British Columbia.
Yeah,
but I moved back to Hawaii when I was like two months old.
It was kind of,
my mom lived in Hawaii.
She was from Canada.
Go back home to have the kids that between brothers will have us two months
later,
boom back,
do I,
so it was that kind of deal.
So you don't have many memories of Victoria.
They're not afraid.
Not only the pictures,
but I've been back a few times.
I've been to Victoria and Toronto actually.
And worries roar.
Where is
over then the east coast for some film.
Anyway,
I digress.
No,
it was,
where did they speak French?
A lot.
Way,
way over there on the,
on the east coast.
Yeah.
I don't know why I can yeah,
my trail.
That was good.
That was really nice.
Materials.
Great City.
Yeah,
Rory Macdonald.
And this was with,
anyway,
back to the Geezer and rash guards.
Um,
we got,
I ate so much at some restaurants,
a Geico was up there for UFC fighter cut weight and then it's time to go reload
Montreal,
Montreal.
And we ended up at this little Italian restaurant and it was insane how good the
guy was making the noodles.
He made everything,
everything he made himself.
And then we get done.
I'm,
you know,
just completely gluttonous.
Lee filled with food and you know,
he comes up,
would you like some dessert?
And I was like,
no,
anymore.
And he says it's the best Tiramisu in the world and I have
a weakness off the program for Tiramisu.
And he brought it out,
he made it and it took them 20 minutes to make and he brought it out.
And it was the best thing that I ever put in my mouth.
It was so good.
Yeah.
Tiramisu is pretty delicious in Montreal,
has excellent restaurants.
I wish I remembered the name of the place,
I'd go back there.
Yeah.
But I don't actually,
I did find that that month we went to a diner.
It was just a diner and it seemed like he was the same thing.
Like they put Carrie in everything,
all the fries or whatever.
Like it was Kinda like Atlanta by the way.
Yeah.
Yeah man,
it's good.
Uh,
nonetheless,
Brash guards.
We do have some new ones coming out from origin and we have our own new ones
coming out.
But uh,
Pete over there at origin,
he makes a warrior kid a rash.
Guards are coming out,
right?
Yeah.
That's going to be at in the store though,
which I'll talk about in a little bit.
Okay,
good story by the way.
Also,
fitness gears it or fitness gear.
If you want to break the loop.
I think that's the theme.
That's what I'm alleviate.
One of the many things.
By the way,
I'm going to leave here with break the loop so you know how people,
they want to get more in back into their fitness or improve their current
fitness.
They want to try kettlebells.
It can be intimidating.
I'm speaking,
I'm speaking from experience,
but break the loop.
Just get one kettle bell.
I think you should get the chimp kettle bell.
They're design.
You know it Kettlebell,
right?
We did talk about chimping.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Inner Gate and all that.
All the themes,
so you get these kettle bells on it.
It's the company called on it on it.com/jocko by the way,
you can get these kettlebells when there isn't.
They're not just a cannon ball with the handle there like a cannon ball shaped
like a champ or a werewolf.
They're pretty dope anyway,
on a.com/jocko check those out and break the loop,
man.
Get it.
Get One,
get two.
I think I have like eight.
No,
legit.
Also self proclaimed legit.
You're not allowed to do that.
I'm not saying I'm legit for doing it even though I am,
but that's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying proclaim yourself as legit.
It did.
So someone make that disclaimer.
That's not what I'm saying.
That's not the point.
The point is my set of kettle bells is legit.
Chimp,
double chimp,
where we'll double werewolf gorilla double grit.
These are go at escalation and weights and one a big foot,
90 pounds.
What's your heaviest one?
I know man.
Two pounds heavier.
Every rep to,
but where's the legit park?
Every rep though every set,
every rep,
two more pounds.
Boom.
Over time.
That is legit.
Also,
when you get maps of meaning by Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson all listed on the website talk,
podcast.com are listed on that website.
Books,
click through there.
That's a good way to support and they come back to Amazon and 12 rules for life.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You can preorder that one.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And it's doing pretty well in preorder.
Sold about 4,000 copies.
Preorders hey.
Yeah.
We'll double that number when this podcast comes out.
That'd be good.
The there,
so yeah,
man,
if you want it.
What's cool is people that listen to this podcast,
they read,
we read books all the time.
They read the books,
they buy the books.
That's it's,
it's awesome.
Oh,
I should say too.
Then I have a book list on my website on Jordan B peterson.com yeah,
that's your book of recommended readings and so if you want to,
well I mean the books,
that had a huge impact on me.
Well,
ordinary man is ordinary members.
One of them and the rape of Nan King as well.
Yeah.
Which is a,
we did a podcast and grouping a lot of man.
You would be very interested in the fall one book to that,
which is called the woman who cared too much,
which is written by Iris Chang's.
Right?
Yeah,
I know I risk committed suicide.
Yeah.
Well,
no wonder after investigating that and being harassed for it,
it's not surprising.
And it seemed like her mom thought it was a lot to do with the drugs she had
been prescribed and going on and off drugs.
And apparently you shouldn't just stop taking one drug and start on some other
drug.
Apparently she would.
She was being directed to do that and it was negatively impactful,
at least according to what her mom thought.
So what a,
what a travesty that was Yemen.
Uh,
yeah,
I'm sure the,
your book list and our book list is probably has a lot of overlap.
Sounds like it's like basically all the books you were talking about,
we already covered,
like we already covered that.
I'm not saying that,
but you know,
like we're familiar with it because it's on the same list.
A lot of overlap.
But yeah,
I've looked at your list and it's actually not a lot of overlap.
There's a,
I mean you obviously have a ton of books on there that,
that um,
a lot of people would be interested in reading that I haven't covered yet.
So yeah,
perhaps what we'll do,
some of them actually.
Yeah.
So yeah.
But yeah.
Well these are going to be on that list again.
Go to [inaudible] dot com on the top little tab.
It's his books from the episodes and I've got it listed by episode,
sometimes multiple books per episode by the way.
So yeah,
go through that.
That's a good way to support.
Click through there and get those books from Amazon.
And if you can do other Amazon shopping,
hey,
carry on.
Do that too.
Good way to support.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already.
Seems obvious.
I know,
but if you haven't,
boom,
subscribe.
The good way to support also on youtube like we talked about,
we only have one channel,
Jordan B.
Peterson has to.
That's good.
Maybe a good idea though,
cause they go to certain channels for certain things.
You know what I mean?
Well,
it's not obvious to what the optimal length of a youtube video is.
You know,
different links serve different functions and different experts will give you
different answers with that.
Very interesting.
Hey,
do you ever listen?
You know how you,
you mentioned that people get your,
your like little clips of your talks and they'll make their own videos.
They'll put some music on that,
you know,
they do that with a lot.
They obviously they do that.
Do you ever like go on there and just kind of watch them and be like,
hey,
I never really,
really felt it like that,
you know,
with that it music era,
it's really interesting what people do with it.
Junk.
Watch mine.
Yeah,
it's funny.
That good.
We made her,
he had this little thing about this,
the expression good.
So it was like,
all right,
let me,
let me make a video made one of those,
made them watch it,
but he liked it.
Somebody made a video where they put me through one of those,
uh,
gadgets that auto tunes your voice.
I was talking about cats and rats.
And so it's like this sort of rap video that's ridiculous.
No,
it's ridiculous.
But
I don't know what to think about 500,000 views.
So you know what,
me and my brother retweeted something as I was telling Michael about this,
you retweet,
you retreated.
Uh,
it's some,
it's some computer sorting,
something sort of numbers.
It,
you can just watch this thing sorted and you'd be posted two or three of them
and I watched all three and it's just kind of funny that how do we get to a
place where we're watching a computer sort things and it's,
well first of all,
why is that on youtube or in the first place?
And I'm sitting there watching it and I'm a,
I'm a person that that constantly tells people don't waste your time on youtube
videos.
And there I was watching,
you know,
three 45 second youtube videos of numbers being sorted,
therapeutic grade like that,
kind of like to see things being sorted or like you ever seen those big domino
patterns,
you know,
that they've made and they just have a video of it.
And you're just watching the domino pattern,
you know,
it's kind of the same.
Well,
we've actually actually,
I feel bad now and we failed to talk about sort yourself out today.
We didn't even use the word sort until right now.
That's a real,
that's a real mistake on my part.
You know,
for those of you that will,
you'll find this as you get into Jordan's work,
you'll see that he talks about sorting yourself out and how that's what you need
to do is sort yourself out.
Yes,
you can buy it on tee shirts and all sorts of things.
So to that and clean your room,
which is,
I really think that's so funny.
It's so,
it's so absurd.
So much of what's happened in the last year.
It's been surreal and absurd,
but that's certainly one of them.
You want to talk about absurd.
The other day I was,
had my daughter cleaning her room and I was playing a joke,
Jordan Peterson clip of you telling people to,
I don't be calling her on her room.
She's getting so mad at me.
But I thought it was fun.
And then,
and then she told me yesterday that she had had a conversation with her friends
about torturous things and mean things that their parents had done.
And that is what she used
me as an instrument of torture.
You are there now?
Yeah.
I didn't understand that.
I can,
I can understand that.
But those youtube clips,
like how you say they made the rap video.
Right.
So I'll let that and like me and my brother would always talk,
he'd always say that what people
do when they add the music to your voice,
it almost gives it like this.
Um,
you know how like when it's might be a crude comparison,
but you know how like dogs,
you got to give them their medicine but you got to put in the food,
you know,
so it's kind of that,
like okay,
you know,
this University of Toronto professor,
I get it.
Maybe a other people might not get it cause it's just this quote unquote boring
lecture.
But then put some cool music behind it.
Yeah.
Well and I think people are doing that because they do find something,
you know,
they find a statement or two that hits them yesterday and they like to play with
it.
And as far as I'm concerned,
like more power to them.
It's really interesting to see how that multiplies out.
You know it's been fascinating to watch that into on artists are rap artists
made a song,
the song is called two free and it's a guy rapping and I forget his name right
now.
I apologize.
But he's rapping and then the song like his rapping fades out and incomes me
talking about discipline equals freedom in the middle of this rap song.
It's like the last minute of his rap song thing and I was going back and forth
with him on Twitter and he's like yeah man I really dug what you said.
I heard it on jre.
Yeah.
So you're like a rapper
the rapper too though.
No you guys both are straight up rap artists,
poet,
author,
Badass Tang.
That's legit right there.
Nonetheless Youtube.
That's a good way to,
to support subscribed Jocko podcast,
the legitimate Jocko podcasts though.
Cause there could be fake accounts.
I remember there were Oh,
podcast,
youtube channel.
That's where you'll see actually it's not very hard to distinguish at this
point.
None the less good way to subscribe.
Also Jocko is a store.
It's called Jocko store.
That's a cool name.
Right?
It's also like direct drive,
right to the point.
The whole deal.
Yeah man.
Just like just like the name of the best ones to have the Jordan Peterson
podcast.
Go and see.
Feel creative.
You scored high on openness.
Have to scratch my head over that one.
You're doing the same boat,
you know,
but it is the legit store.
Nonetheless.
I'm still a basic store,
but what we've got on there and got some shirts,
some rash guards for digital and surfing actually for pretty much any physical
activity,
cycling,
whatever.
Um,
also some women's stuff on there and hats.
Hoodies are out for the winter,
so he's from Canada.
He needs legit.
He's from Hawaii.
He's not,
he's from Hawaii.
And last hoodies that he made were thinner than your shirt that you're wearing
right now.
They were inappropriate as hoodies.
So he beefed it up again this year.
Slight exaggeration,
but true nonetheless.
So yeah,
they're,
they're thicker hoodies for sure.
And they're in some patches on there.
Again,
some women's stuff for you,
you know the lady trooper after it.
Um,
so yeah,
should be all good on there.
Uh,
some new stuff coming out,
going to let you guys wait on what those things are.
Anyway,
let's just go store.com.
That's a good,
I know.
Like it's this big thing,
you know,
there's four people that are waiting till the next day.
I'm just saying that's the one talking to him.
Boom.
Anyway,
it's called [inaudible] dot com.
Easy to remember also.
Okay,
so psychological warfare tell you what that is.
Makes sense to.
So when you're on the path,
that's what we're calling it,
right?
The Path.
Yeah.
Discipline.
Right.
And when you know how like,
okay,
I'm going to check,
you got to keep doing that stuff.
You know,
you can't just be like,
I'm going to quit drinking and then just quit drinking for one day.
You got to do it for,
for good.
But some days you find that it's like hard,
like with Seminole wake up four 30 in the morning every morning.
Now for the rest of my life,
one day it's going to be like I can't do,
I'm going to hit snooze.
But now psychological warfare,
it's an album with tracks you can get on iTunes,
whatever.
And each track is for each little weakness that might come up.
See what I'm saying?
So let's say you're about to wake up you and hit the snooze instead of the
snooze.
Psychological warfare.
Get up and get after it.
That's the name of the truck.
It'll have Jocko telling you pragmatically why you shouldn't do that,
why you should stay strong,
stay on it.
Stay on the path you campaign against weakness.
And also,
you know,
it's,
it goes for a bunch of stuff.
Like,
um,
you want to skip the workout that day or you're procrastinating,
you know,
I'm gonna leave it for tomorrow.
Whatever.
Create a block,
all that stuff anyway.
It's called psychological warfare.
Check it out.
See if the it see if any one or more of the tracks addresses your potential
weakness on your path.
That's what it's for
and that by the way,
that that album was the number one spoken word album for something like nine
months and it was only recently,
and this is on iTunes.
It was only recently overtaken by another album that's called the discipline
equals freedom field manual.
What do aversion audio version,
which is now on iTunes and Amazon music and Google play and other,
did you read it?
Yes.
You did?
Yes,
because I'd been thinking about reading my,
Oh you absolutely should.
I read this,
I read this with my buddy leaf and this book,
the kids book way,
the where your kid,
my son read,
he read the kid and I read Uncle Jake so I have fun with that kind of thing.
Also when you're an Amazon you can get Jocko white tea,
which you may want to try it.
Do you ever dead lift weights?
Okay.
This will give you a minimum dead lift of 8,000 pounds.
If you drink Jocko white tea and it's guaranteed it's work that is more than
I've ever been able to dead lift.
Well there you go.
You're stuck at that 7,000 pounds.
You need to get to [inaudible].
It will get you there 100% also on Amazon obviously we got the books,
Jordan's books,
maps of meaning and 12 rules for life.
Preorder it.
The thing that this is what's going to happen and I had to warn people that it
was going to happen and it's going to happen to your book to your publisher
doesn't understand what's happening.
They don't understand youtube.
They don't understand your podcast.
They don't understand this podcast.
They can understand Joe Rogan's podcast.
They don't understand that and so they're printing books and they think,
Oh yeah,
we think it's going to do okay.
The book is going to sell out so people don't preorder the book.
They won't get,
there's two things.
First of all,
they won't get it when it comes out and second of all they won't get the first
edition copy,
which is kind of like if you're a book guy,
you want that thing.
If you want it to be first edition.
So if you want his book,
which you do,
preorder it,
do it now.
Um,
way the warrior kid,
if you want to put your kid,
if you want to sort your kit out and put them on the proper path,
the proper path,
get them book way.
The warrior kid,
you said you read it?
Yep.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's funny.
I use that term too in my,
in my book the proper path.
My editor asked me quite repair repetitively.
I'd say what exactly what I meant by that,
but it's,
you know,
sort of implicit in the book,
but proper is the right word for that.
For some reason it's,
even though it's kind of an old word in some ways,
old fashioned word,
that's okay.
There's a lot of old fashioned words that we could,
that we could use.
Again,
I agree.
And I,
I wrote this book because all the books that were out there for kids,
we're telling them that there was okay to be weak and that it was okay to do bad
in school and maybe they weren't smart enough to,
to know their times tables and all of these.
So maybe it's okay if you're scared of the water,
maybe should just stay away from the water.
It's like,
no,
no and no.
Do you want,
yeah,
it's not okay to be like that,
but it is okay to be strong and it is okay to study hard and work hard.
It is okay to face your fears.
Yeah.
It's okay to stand up to the bully.
It's okay to do those things.
It's proper to do this thing so far.
Well,
that's the problem with that damn self esteem movement.
It's like,
you know what you're supposed to be telling kids is that who you are is more
important.
Who you could be as more important than who you are because you're living it.
It's like,
what do you live in for your,
you know,
if,
if you're already everything you should be,
it's like,
well,
you know,
you're done.
So what good is it growing up?
That's not helpful.
It's like you say,
look man,
you're full of potential.
There's,
there's worlds out there to conquer.
There's things to do.
There's people to help.
There's things to put right.
Get the hell together,
get it together.
And don't let your fears stop you
as opposed to everything's great and you're,
you're,
you're this wonderful child.
Why would you want to then burden yourself with a bunch of responsibility?
That doesn't make any sense.
I'm already good to go.
Yeah,
you're right.
No,
unburdened me.
that's not true because they're not like ended.
Well,
people in general notice because they're not satisfied with their life.
They have a feeling that there's gotta be more,
well,
there is more,
but the more isn't by radical self acceptance of all your pathetic floors,
right?
Uh,
extreme ownership.
Another book you can get,
it's about personal responsibility and how that will make you win as a leader.
So get that book.
If you don't have it yet and if you don't have,
if you have it and you want your team to be better,
get the book for your team so that they start taking ownership of the problems
that and,
and then the problems start getting solved.
Discipline equals freedom.
Um,
field manual.
It's out.
Thanks to everyone that bought it and made it into a bestseller on New York
Times bestseller or Wall Street Journal Bestseller.
Those things are cool.
Guess what?
Appreciate it.
Appreciate all you out there buying the book,
spreading a word.
All,
everyone that's sent pictures of 12 books stacked up that you're buying for
everyone on your team or everyone you know,
or you're buying them for Christmas and your dad and your uncle.
Thank you for doing that.
Um,
because not only does it help the book do well and continue to help the book do
well,
it's also gonna help those people out in my opinion.
I agree.
Not that everyone's going to get it.
Some people are going to go,
this book is stupid.
Impossible.
You know,
and what we talked about earlier,
some people read the book and they go,
Oh,
I already knew that.
Well,
of course you did,
but why didn't you do it?
Why didn't you do it?
Because someone obviously thinks you need to do it.
So okay,
you get it.
That's fine.
Yeah.
You know what you're supposed to do.
Guess what?
We all know what we're supposed to do.
We all know what's going to improve our station in life and what's going to make
it worse.
Why aren't you doing the things that you're supposed to do?
Question.
I Dunno.
Now you've got a man.
You actually do you want to know why?
Because you lack the discipline.
You lack the discipline to do the things you know you're supposed to do.
Don't.
Oh,
you might also lack the fear so I could actually matters if you don't do it
matters.
If you leave things undone,
you leave the world in an uncompleted state and it hurts.
It hurts you.
It hurts your family,
it hurts your society,
and it hurts the world.
So if you're laying there being useless and not getting out at,
then you're contributing to the catastrophe.
And it's that simple.
So it actually matters if you do it.
And I think sometimes people don't do it cause they don't understand that,
you know,
they're,
they're down on themselves.
They don't think they matter.
It's like you matter a lot more than you think you,
you do an actually that's rather frightening,
you know,
because you think,
well wouldn't it be nice if everybody mattered?
It's like you got to think that through.
If what you do matters,
you better look out,
so get at it because you're going to pay for it if you don't.
Sure.
No.
Thank you.
Yes.
I,
I obviously agree that and,
and a lot of people have been asking for the audio version and like I said,
it's on the MP three platforms.
It's on Google play,
iTunes,
Amazon music,
Spotify.
Yes.
Spotify,
I think you can ask Alexa to play it right.
If you have digital thing in Europe that if it's on Amazon music,
I think it automatically does it.
I don't know for sure.
But you know,
um,
if you need some leadership support training at your team or Your Business
Ashkelon Front,
that is the leadership consultant company.
It's me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
info@echelonfront.com.
We'll come and get after it with you and your leadership team.
If you want to keep this conversation going,
you can hit all of us up on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
Instagram,
and on the face.
Ball key echo is at echocharles.
I am at Jocko Willink and Jordan is Jordan B.
Peterson on Twitter,
Jordan B.
Peterson on Youtube,
and Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson on Facebook.
And like I said,
you also have the podcast as well echoed to
Nico Vink closing thoughts.
That's it.
Thank you so much.
Hey,
thanks for the invitation.
It's been great.
Yeah,
it looks like we're uh,
doing the same thing from different directions.
So that's,
and not so different even.
So that's pretty cool.
So yeah,
that's good.
Anything else from you?
Nope,
don't think so.
I appreciate it.
And we'll,
we'll,
we'll get you back on here before 12 rules comes out and we'll talk about that
book.
And a little bit more detail.
I'll get you an advanced copy.
Awesome.
And thank you for coming on obviously,
but more important,
thanks for being out there.
Thanks for spreading a positive message.
Again,
very aligned with what I say.
You're coming at people from a diff,
totally different angle than I come from.
But that message I think is gonna make people better,
which in turn,
as you just said,
is going to make the world a better place.
And I know,
I know that you are working hard to make this happen and I truly appreciate the
fact that you are doing that.
So it doesn't seem like there's anything better to do.
Good.
Well
that's kind of,
it seems like a basic truth,
doesn't it?
It's like there are things that aren't so good we could probably fix most of
the,
so like what you got something better to do than that.
It doesn't seem like it,
but let's at least have a good shot at it.
Yeah,
right.
exactly.
Exactly.
And to the people that make this podcast possible.
And that is the soldiers,
sailors,
airmen,
and Marines on the front lines who protect our right to free speech.
Those folks that are living out the archetype of the hero,
they're out there fighting the dragon and killing the snakes and protecting us
from evil.
Thanks to all you service men and women for protecting us and to police and law
enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
and other first responders.
Thank you for keeping us safe on the home front and to everyone else that is
listening.
Remember this,
there is evil in the world.
There are snakes and there are dragons and there are deprived human beings and
pathologies that can rip you apart.
But there is also your world that you control and you have the ability to stand
up against evil and against those snakes in your own way
and make your world a better place.
So stand up
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is Dr. Jordan Peterson and echo and Jocko out.